Three,
two,
one,
boom.
What's up brother?
We'll see you my friend.
Oh ways.
Thanks for having wild man.
Yeah,
we both been busy.
It's crazy.
And in the meantime we'd became legal.
Yes,
you guys were at the forefront,
man.
You guys were way ahead.
You were ahead of everybody.
You know,
we took a shot,
he took a shot,
you know,
it's donors and advocates and whatnot.
You know,
we were stoners at first.
Right.
You know,
that's how you start.
Like,
you know,
your friend says,
hey man,
try this.
Or you're the one who says try this.
Right.
It's one or the other.
And you know,
eventually you start getting into the high times magazines and stuff like that
and looking at the,
you know,
the center full pictures of the weed.
But also we like,
we like to read too hastily.
So,
you know,
we'd get into some of the activism aspect of it as well.
And that's when we heard names like Jack Herrera,
who pretty much opened our eyes to everything.
And then,
you know,
I think we became real advocates.
You know,
at first,
you know,
we thought we were,
sort of,
we read the high times of magazines that we were stoners,
so we thought we were advocates,
but like in reading what other freedom fighters were actually doing out there
and protest and rallies and all that stuff.
You know,
we,
we really weren't advocates.
Like we thought we became that later for sure.
Yeah.
Jack was way,
way,
way ahead of the curve and he's just such an interesting story.
Uh,
rest in peace because he was a Goldwater Republican,
you know,
he was just a button down old school republic.
Yeah.
And then he got a girlfriend and then the girlfriend and got him smoking weed
and then all of a sudden he was like,
man,
this is fucking amazing.
God.
Why am I such a Dick?
What's wrong with me?
Who am I?
What am I doing with my life?
Absolutely.
It totally flipped his life around.
The emperor wears no clothes.
The fucking great book,
man.
Yeah,
it holds,
it holds strong to this day because everything that he said in the book is sort
of happening right now.
All the stuff that they,
you know,
they,
uh,
tried to prevent from happening through all the anti cannabis propaganda.
You see it now and now you see those very companies tried to get into the
industry if they were always on the outside of the waiting,
you know,
there was all like that,
the launching block not quite ready to run,
but uh,
any minute now it's going to get legal.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean,
you know,
they're,
they're lying in wait with fields like acreage that no one can ever come close
to probably.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean the,
the thing I heard maybe like five years ago before it was legal in Denver,
that was a bit bit longer than that before we got legalization here.
Um,
that,
you know,
companies like Philip Morris and,
and you know,
companies like that we're already buying land in already.
I'm trademarking names,
you know,
for some of the cannabis that we know today so that when they come into the
game,
you know,
they have ownership on some of the names in some of the brands and trademarks
and stuff like that to that.
And obviously the acreage to,
you know,
grow vast sums of cannabis.
You know,
who knows how true that is,
but I don't doubt some of that.
I don't doubt it either.
As sneaky as shit was Ohio,
Ohio was,
they were trying to make it legal,
but if there were going to make it illegal,
there's only like,
it took two companies that were on Jamie's from Ohio,
think like four.
But I think that is how it went.
Yeah.
We're the only ones going to be allowed to grow it and sell it.
Like fuck a fuck you monopoly.
That is not legal weed.
That is you being a cunt.
That's a monopoly and it's crazy,
you know?
Yeah.
Because you know,
you had like people that got those uh,
licenses or permits or whatever that had no knowledge on,
on,
on the cannabis culture or,
or business how to cultivate and,
and how to run retail stores or any of that.
And they didn't have any of that knowledge.
And you know,
Dell usually give it to an insider because they know how much money they stand.
To me that's like if there was just one distribution center,
right,
and everybody has to go through that distribution center,
how much money does that distribution center make me?
Cause you gotta pay for your shit to go there.
And then,
you know,
who knows if it,
well,
you know,
if it passes because you know as a cultivator what you did,
so you'll know it'll pass cause it's clean,
but you still got to pay that fee every time and it's got to go through them.
Fortunately here in California,
you know,
they allowed people to have distribution licenses so that there's not one
distribution center because that would be a monopoly for sure.
And that's what they wanted to supposedly,
you know,
the lobbyists that,
that puts 64 together.
We're trying to stop it from a monopoly and uh,
corporations coming in and taking over and stuff like that.
You know,
so interesting.
Because pot is such a non-corporate drug and it's such a non corporate thing
that these corporations were trying to get a grip on weed.
It just,
it seemed,
it seemed obscene.
You know,
it seemed seemed disgusting.
Yeah.
It's a little out of place,
you know,
a lot on a place.
Right.
You know,
because you,
you,
you think about where it comes from and it's been outlawed for so long.
It's kind of like,
you know,
the way our alcohol was for so long,
but as longer than alcohol,
but it's been demonized longer.
Yes.
And now,
you know,
you have people trying to come in and throw money into it and they got,
in some of these guys don't realize it's not just about the money until you got
to do the diligence on what this business is.
You can't cut corners on the cultivation.
You know,
you can't cut corners on quality because people,
you know,
they're,
um,
there's more information out there.
You the ENL,
so people know e even if they're not a connoisseur sewer as a consumer,
you know,
they can,
they can read about shit,
they can learn about stuff.
So if you're getting over on a more,
if you're putting some shit,
quality product out there,
I mean people are gonna know and,
and all that money that these guys put into to trying to get into the cannabis
business,
they're just throwing it into the fire.
Some of them will come out of it,
you know,
they'll partner up with brands did exist and people that have knowledge,
but you know,
it's,
it's the corporations that come in,
in the next five years.
It's going to be,
it's going to be interesting because I do think that it's set up for them to
come in.
The taxes are so high right now for the consumer and for the cultivator and for
the retail shop that you got to survive this wash.
Right now it's happening in order to still be,
you know,
doing business when the corporate structure comes in because please believe
they're going to lobby so that those taxes come down because the margins are not
right.
You know,
as 40% tax.
Is that what it is now?
It was 39 in Denver,
right?
Yeah.
But in here,
in California,
it's,
you know,
40% into the consumer.
The consumer's like,
who gives a fuck?
If I could just pull in and get some weed,
really should give a fuck.
Cause,
but in comparison to alcohol,
like how much it costs,
if you go out for a night for some drinks,
that costs way more.
You get high for a month and what it takes to get pretty much she drinks in a
night.
It depending where you go,
those fucking drinks or even double.
Yeah.
And with less alcohol.
Well the other thing is that these companies,
they don't understand the culture.
It's a different culture.
You can't bullshit us.
Yeah.
You can't bullshit us with marketing and advertising.
That shit is not going to work.
You can't have like the most interesting man in the world selling weed.
Stay,
stay thirsty.
My friends.
No.
Now that ain't going to work.
You got to get somebody like Michael Phelps.
Yeah man,
I would buy weed from Michael Phelps.
How funny was that?
That he got in trouble for that?
You know what?
I find it funny is how,
how um,
you know,
they,
they put these stereotypes on stoners for so long like that we are lazy and
productive and all that stuff.
This guy's one of the most decorated Olympian in the history.
You know what I mean?
What does he got like 15 gold fucking models.
Preposterous.
Yeah.
Mr Big lungs.
That's what we call him mister big lungs.
Fuck.
I probably could take a rip on a bond.
Think about it and God ain't shit right.
He had it probably is crazy capacity there.
It is.
Probably snap a two gram bull.
This guy,
the person who ratted him out some low,
some kids,
some terp little dickhead.
What a piece of shit.
Yeah.
Imagine it's going to a party trying to have a good time.
Some kids there with his phone.
That's social network for you though.
They want to go viral so they'll,
they'll get you in that moment where you know you're supposed to be a friend.
But that was like before all out of that shit was happening.
Like what year was that?
Let's guess.
What gear was that?
12 2012.
Well before.
Yeah.
Before a,
let's just say before,
you know,
uh,
Instagram kicked off,
but there was still youtube and Twitter.
Yeah.
And you know,
if you wanted to put somebody on blast or you wanted to have a viral video,
youtube has been there for a long time.
Yeah.
Twitter was like 2007 right?
It wasn't that.
I believe so.
Yeah.
I think when was Michael,
why don't,
was it Michael Phelps?
When did he get in trouble?
I'm looking at,
I,
I'm seeing different stuff,
so I saw a picture of it on youtube from 2009.
So that means it would have been in 2008 Olympics.
But that seems,
that makes sense.
Like it was a long time ago.
Yeah,
that makes sense though,
because he did it,
came back,
right?
Yeah.
He retired and then he came back,
well,
I think he was suspended.
They get suspended.
2009 is when he got caught.
And then,
uh,
and then he had to,
you know,
do the suspension and he came back and got some more metals like,
Haha,
fuck you.
Right.
I love that he's suspended because of the weed.
Yeah.
Well you know,
hey,
listen on,
on uh,
in a lot of places it's still on a a banned substance list.
Oh yeah.
Texas.
Texas is real bad.
February two thought,
well 2009,
he was only 23 apologize can incident where he's caught on camera to party
smoking a bomb that was allegedly marijuana.
He should,
you know,
he shouldn't have apologized for that.
He shouldn't have had to have apologized for that thing.
Is that they have those guys bent over a box because they're all just trying to
get that sponsorship by right as,
yeah.
You have to be squeaky clean.
If you want to be on the Wheaties box,
you can't be an Olympian.
Yeah,
they're not going to put Cypress Hill on the Wheaties box.
Wouldn't that be great though,
but take the t h out,
add an e and put a d and n I e s n plus go weedies.
Yeah,
I dunno man.
You guys where it's so far ahead of the curve though.
You know,
I mean you,
you were,
you had we'd songs like when like what year that was,
uh,
the,
the first album was in 91 and we started riding for that album probably a four
years prior.
And uh,
you know,
the weeds,
songs those came about because we were,
we'd heads,
you know,
we just fuck it,
let's be ourselves.
Right.
Different thing now for people that were,
were fans because uh,
I,
when I was listening to you,
I was just getting ready to move from Boston to New York and uh,
back then you would hear about new hip hop bands from Mike Friends.
Yeah.
Like you didn't like it was all word of mouth.
I'm not sure I would hear about it like somebody that I think somebody I worked
out with had it and I was like,
what the fuck is this?
And then like that Cypress Hill,
I was like,
Damn.
Yeah,
we're trying to be different.
You know,
I'm not sound a typical west coast,
you know,
group,
because a lot of a lot of west coast groups at that point,
you know,
what the labels were looking for were Nwa,
types and you know,
things like that.
Like either,
you know,
gangster,
west coast,
gangster rap,
they were looking for that or either the kid frost Chicano type.
And we didn't want to do that.
We didn't want to a foot hold ourselves like that,
you know,
mugs being from New York,
he wanted to sort of blend both worlds,
right.
So,
you know,
we went with,
with the east coast type sound with La,
you know,
type of slang mixed with,
with east coast slang.
And so people,
you know,
they were like,
where the fuck are these guys from?
And people thought we were from Cypress Hill in New York because there's a
Cypress hill down there.
And uh,
you know,
people just didn't really know at first because we were one of the first groups
that didn't put our images on any of our first,
um,
you know,
any of our singles or,
or our art covers.
We never did like the,
the shots,
like you know,
that that were existing at that time where you,
it's a clean shot of the group or the artist or whatever.
We were always on some,
you know,
cause we were metal heads too,
before the hip hop.
We liked the obscure metal albums.
So we didn't,
we were like,
we're not going to put ourselves on the covers.
We're just going to do these crazy obscure covers and make people,
you know,
try to guess who we are.
Be Mysterious,
Dan.
We talk about longevity.
I mean you guys,
you guys have been around a long fucking time and dropped off at all.
It's crazy.
You know.
Um,
we,
we didn't expect it.
We didn't know how long I run would be.
We just kept working with w always had a strong work ethic.
We were never the types just to sit around.
We're always doing something,
you know,
mugs,
always making beats.
Um,
you know,
I'm always writing to something.
I'm always into one project or another.
So it was always just about keeping busy and,
and that,
that,
uh,
suited as well.
It's crazy.
28 years later,
still fanning in it.
It's crazy what you say 28 years later from your first album,
Matt and again,
you guys never dropped off for a second.
Not once.
You were always there.
You have to be consistent in hip hop.
You know,
in music in general,
especially like if,
if there's a time where radio stops playing your music or you know as MTV stop
playing music videos and they went for more um,
reality show type programming,
you got to,
you got to stick out there.
So for us it was,
you know,
constantly doing shows.
We didn't put out as many albums as we could of,
but we thought less was more,
you know,
instead of like drive in the music into your heart like a steak or something
like that.
We just,
you know,
let everything breathe for a while.
And there was,
there was a time where,
you know,
we sort of let go of doing everything.
It was like a six year period where we just kind of took off.
We,
we didn't,
we weren't away completely.
We're still doing like sporadic shows here and there to keep up the profile.
But we weren't like touring and working on music.
I was off fucking around,
uh,
competing in paintball tournaments that couldn't get into paintball.
Oh Man.
Uh,
yeah.
I had a team called stone assassins and it was competitive paintball at the
time.
I was,
you know,
training,
uh,
martial arts is I've done throughout my life.
And,
uh,
I was also playing competitive paintball and a martial arts we're doing showed a
con.
I started off with taekwondo and I got sort of,
I mean it's,
it's like,
it was,
uh,
the Dojo was cool,
you know,
and,
and I was progressing quickly,
but I sort of fell out with the master there with the sea floor,
whatever.
I can't remember what it is.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
one of my partners who I grew up with who is one of my partners in our Dr. Green
thumb,
um,
Brandon,
whatever his father,
um,
was,
uh,
you know,
Sensei and his sensei and became my sensei.
I went from taekwondo to shadow con and I started training with him.
I mean,
he had been in the Dojo since he was five years old training with his father.
So,
you know,
I came into that,
it took,
it took a little bit of a convincing for me to go from one thing to another
because it's such a different style.
Um,
but,
you know,
I adapted to it and I liked it and it was,
um,
very different,
less flash,
but uh,
is very disciplined in his father.
You know,
he was,
you know,
born in Japan,
raised out there and he,
he,
you know,
there,
there she is kind of different.
They go to,
to,
to um,
martial arts universities and they get degrees in different martial arts so they
can go and take like,
okay,
hop Kido and Jujitsu and showed [inaudible] and all of this and you know,
get their,
their degrees,
you know,
the work that were up in the belt system and all that stuff.
But they become teachers through,
through that university,
I guess.
Fascinating.
And,
uh,
yeah,
his,
his father was one of the guys in one of the federations that,
uh,
he's one of the three or four Sensei's.
It have to come in and give you the black belt when you actually get it.
Yeah.
What was it?
A S K o f a or something like I got,
you know,
I'm just done karate federation.
So yeah,
something like that.
So you could imagine when Leo Machida came on the scene,
you know,
we were like,
yeah,
someone representing the style that,
you know,
we were trained under anyway.
A lot of people got excited when he came about.
He was really the first guy to legitimize karate in the modern era of mixed
martial arts.
You show up,
like if you could do all those other things,
if you could stuff takedowns and you,
you knew submissions and all those things on top of that you could live.
Yeah,
you could.
And you could do it in a weird way that people didn't really understand his
timing.
And Wonderboy Thompson similar to that too.
It's got a weird timing.
Weird timing,
you know,
and then the faints with the hips and he was good with that shit.
Like you know,
he,
he would throw people off with that.
And you know,
we,
I just happened to go see his fight against Rashad Evans.
Oh Shit.
And a man.
I mean,
it surprised all of us.
we thought he would win,
but we didn't know he would win in that fashion.
I mean,
yeah,
he was something special,
you know what I mean?
And he's doing,
but he's over at Bellator now,
right.
With his brother,
his brother Chins.
Oh.
Has Been,
uh,
over there for a while.
His brother,
I think his brother's a Bantam weight or featherweight,
one of those.
But um,
yeah,
that,
that I think it's good to go from taekwondo to other styles because taekwondo
gives you a lot of dexterity.
You weren't going to move your legs easily.
Yes,
absolutely.
It's a good foundation.
Yeah.
It's a good way to start off.
It's good for little kids to the guest that doesn't,
you know,
there's not a lot of head contact.
They're kind of working nation to.
Yeah.
And then when you learn,
if you learn,
if you really actually want to fight,
you want to learn more time.
And I was other things you have way quicker,
legs.
And just move better.
Yeah.
For me,
you know,
I was never good with all those flashy cook kicks like that.
So you know,
big dude.
Yeah.
It was harder for me.
Taekwondo,
like the shadow Khan was definitely hard,
but it was more suited for someone my size and style show the kinds of hard it
is.
And He,
you know,
he,
when he was training as he would not like let up is eat the whole be reels here,
let me go light on him.
Nah,
everything I did like,
you know that they did,
I did outside of music when I tried it.
Like for instance,
paint ball,
when they went into paintball,
there was a price on my head.
Every game,
everybody wanted to give me extra shots.
So like if I got hit well I'm walking out,
I would get 10 20 extra paint balls to my back.
Oh.
You know,
and we'd give it right back to them,
you know,
in the very next game when we played them guys again,
we were making sure to give them that right back.
But you got deep into this.
Oh yeah.
It was man,
it,
it's addicting.
That I got to tell you.
Um,
if there's any physical activity that is addicting.
It is paintball cause it's chest with guns because it's so fast and so close and
you got to think of a strategy,
you know,
it's not all shooting straight way.
It's all shooting angles in getting your guys to positions to get those guys out
to keep moving up,
to get their flag,
wipe them out and bring the flag back.
Now are there restrictions on power?
Like the power of the guns?
Yeah,
I believe you can't shoot above 300 PSI.
I think it's,
I think it's a,
the highest you can shoot as maybe to 85 to 90 at least at the time.
If you go balls out,
if you wanted to get the ultimate paintball gun,
what is that?
Oh man,
it's,
it's hard because we were using different guns at the time cause it's,
it's like a,
each year a better gun comes out,
the technology gets better.
So you know,
we were using it first when we started these these guns called angels and then
we went over into these other guns.
Fuck,
I can't remember the name of them but they were light.
I mean the best thing is to have a light gun with,
with the that you can fan see cause that's the technique to get it to shoot like
a,
like a Uzi.
Right.
You're not supposed to be able to pull the trigger and multiple balls come out
with one pole.
It's supposed to be that the gun shoots as fast as your,
your,
your two fingers or three can toggle.
So if you get a rhythm you could shoot that thing like a fucking Uzi,
you know,
and everybody has a different position,
like mine,
I was like one of the quarterbacks,
which is the last three on the line.
See it's like a football field,
right?
You got the 50 and there's obstacles at the 50 and in between and it's mirrored
on the other side.
The quarterbacks play the back and they shoot a whole bunch of paint so that the
other guys that are the front and mid guys can get into these different
positions to shoot the other guys out.
So the guys in the back were shooting the most pain.
So you have to use that fanning,
um,
style.
So using three fingers,
three fingers,
cause the trigger where your,
where the,
the base,
where you're pulling the trigger,
you can fit three fingers there.
It's really for two.
But you could fit three.
Yeah.
This,
this was our team right here.
It's still a necessity.
And we were always pretty stoned when we were planning.
Did that help?
Yeah.
The,
the,
the furthest we went,
we took third place in one tournament.
Wow.
You guys.
So this is crazy.
Like you guys have these barriers and shit and these are all blow up barriers
right here.
It's like a football field.
Yeah.
That's what they would replicate.
Like a football,
soccer field.
And,
uh,
you know,
you put all the,
these,
these obstacles up,
these blow up obstacles and uh,
they're all just positions to,
to try to take,
to get a better angle on the other side.
And what's the ultimate goal to take everybody out?
It's uh,
you get points for taking the other side out,
but you get the maximum points getting their flag and bringing it back to
yourself.
And you know,
you get points for how many guys on your side that are still alive.
So,
you know,
you would get 100% if all seven of your guys were alive,
you killed all of them and brought their flag that ever happened.
Oh yeah.
Damn.
Who are you planning,
uh,
you know,
kids crawling around.
The thing about paintball,
right,
is that,
let's just say there's six tiers,
right?
There's the pros,
there's a semi-pros,
there's the amateurs,
there's the novice,
there's the rookie.
And uh,
each,
each tier had at least 200 teams competing in this wow per tournament.
And these guys back in that time,
I don't know how it,
how it is now cause I haven't competed in a long time,
but they would do five tournaments a year.
One would be in Huntington beach,
the biggest one.
And it was awesome.
They would throw it,
you know,
right next to a surfing tournament.
So like it would just be cross people crossing up,
watching the surfers and they'd come and watch and the paintball then it would
hit,
you know,
Boston and Florida and Las and one other,
one other place.
I can't remember.
But we would do these tournaments.
I was doing them for like four or five years.
And the guy before me that was the,
the ambassador was uh,
one of the,
one of the bgs,
bgs,
the one who passed away first.
Um,
Barry Gibb's wasn't buried.
Now he's the one that always wear the hat.
Um,
he was the shorter one.
So he was a paintball.
She was a paintball fiend.
Like myself.
He owned a store.
He had a team,
I think it was based out of a flow out of Miami and he would compete up until
when he passed away.
He was like the ambassador and I kind of is.
Yeah,
I came in and took his spot when he's,
yeah,
Maurice Maurice Gift.
That's crazy.
I had no idea why you guys are armored the fuck up.
These things won't sting.
Oh Man.
I mean I'd leave with at least 20 paintball bruises,
you know Pr,
you know in one one sitting and you know you're,
you're,
you look like a leopard coming,
coming off after that.
You know who else was a big paintball enthusiasts was William Shatner.
Really?
Yeah.
He would hold these crazy tournaments like in Trekkie style where?
Access scenario game meaning that,
okay,
here's the castle.
I'm going to be in the castle right here.
You guys got it?
Sieged the castle and if you guys can come get me out of here,
you guys win this round and they would see it through the three days.
They'd set up different scenarios like there he goes to a pay phone.
This is crazy.
I would have never guessed.
But how does he run?
He can't run.
Well,
no,
he's old.
He doesn't run.
They,
they put him in a central place and he'll shoot.
Sometimes he would go out there,
but so he would just stay put.
Yeah,
he would stay put.
You would have to protect him.
Old Man paint ball.
He would fight.
He would fight too.
But he would,
he would,
you know,
they would be trying to protect him.
Oh,
that's so crazy.
Yeah.
Wow.
And uh,
I mean there's a bunch of celebrities that,
that paint bald.
Matt Will Smith was paintball and before he did I,
robot really?
He did that.
He came down to the park where we would practice that we played with Tim and his
team.
Um,
but it was a scenario game.
A Joaquin Phoenix,
we MCI Pfeiffer.
I mean,
you'd be surprised how many,
but it looks like fun.
I guess I shouldn't be surprised.
You let off steam.
Yeah.
I mean people on a team,
on a competition team,
you have,
uh,
you have 11 for the roster in seven play at a time and you can,
you know,
switch guys out.
But now it's different.
Now they do like five men in three men teams.
I don't know anything about the new style but you know,
they,
they constantly call me back cause I'm in better shape than I was when I played.
I was a little bit heavier than I was at quarterback.
You know,
it wasn't running too fast then.
But you know that always hit me man.
I'll always get hit on my DM on Igg or Twitter like hey man,
when you come back to paypal feeling like when I get time,
which is probably never,
but it seems like a a big time suck.
Loved it man.
I love to play in the game.
It was so addicting.
It was hard to pull away from it.
I would even at times be coming home from,
from a tour straight into a tournament.
Like I'd get off the plane,
I'd have somebody have my paint ball shit ready and boom straight to the
tournament.
Can't tell you how many times I was doing that.
Yeah.
It's fucking crazy.
It's funny when things get in your blood,
right?
Getting your bones.
Yeah.
That got in my blood like martial arts did.
Cause I was always like an enthusiast like you know,
for,
for a long time,
you know.
And uh,
when I finally started training,
I was training like seven days a week.
Man.
I wouldn't give myself any time off because I wanted to learn fast and I wanted
to absorb it,
you know?
Did you ever fuck with you Jitsu?
No.
Uh,
I always wanted to,
but I never did.
I thought about it and a,
the 10th planet man,
he fit right in.
And I think I will,
you know,
like a lot of people have asked me and invited me cause they know,
I'm a UFC fan.
I'm a mixed martial arts fan.
I'm a boxing fan,
you know all that shit at,
you know,
a couple of my cousins are,
well,
one of them was a champion professional boxer,
which was Michael Carbo Hall and his nephew.
Your cousin.
Yes,
I met my,
I met him one day at the comedy store.
Yeah.
Long time ago,
man.
Yeah,
when he was a,
when he was a champ,
he was a beast.
He was a beast and his nephew is now now boxing Keenan Carbo.
Oh,
okay,
cool.
So yeah,
you know,
we're rooting for family right there,
but from Arizona,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So yeah,
I've been invited to,
to,
you know,
come fuck with Jujitsu and I think I,
I think I will because I mean,
you got to know it,
I think,
I think you,
you know,
it's something that would benefit anyone from to know that.
So it's,
you don't actually,
you know,
get in a fight and have to hurt somebody bad or they hurt you.
You know what I'm saying?
Just choke him.
Just choke him out.
I saw Everlast choke some guy out one night and it was the fucking cause you
know,
he,
he fucks around a little bit and you know,
he knows people that did teach Jujitsu and they've taught him a couple of
things.
And we're at the rainbow one night where we were holding court,
I'm just smoking like it's Amsterdam down there.
And we were having a conversation and he kept hearing some dude across the
cross,
a couple of tables over kept saying,
Everlast this Everlast that and he,
he yo money,
say my name one more time.
And he goes,
Everlast.
And he went back to talking to his people because he did.
Dick Everlast was good.
Come up and do nothing ever lasts.
Went,
walked over to this table,
look to his face,
turned them around real quick and start choking him.
Say My name again.
Muddy say.
Oh man,
it was,
it was hilarious.
But uh,
yeah man,
10th planet is downtown right near where your places.
Yeah.
So your studio or your set up that's,
that's real close to 10 plan Jujitsu.
Yeah,
man.
Just let me know.
I'll set up a will,
man,
you gotta avoid any flat earth conversations that come up.
Oh I,
you know,
like eight years and keep moving.
I get those from,
I get those from time to time.
You know,
I get a flatter stay the fuck off of Youtube,
man,
man.
Yeah,
they get confused.
that's it.
That's the craziest shit.
Cause I always argue like this about the flat earth,
right?
So,
hey listen,
if we got a flatter,
there's an edge,
right?
And there's always thrill seekers looking to do something thrilling.
And there's always a thrill seeker that fucks up and falls right off of that
edge.
Right?
So how many motherfuckers would be fallen off the edge of the earth if we really
had one?
For sure.
You know,
there'll be climbers,
there'd be a bunch of dudes who would try to hang off the edge to take selfies.
Think about it,
right?
12 people this year have died at the Grand Canyon Nest,
the Grand Canyon.
It was that really that many,
that many so far in this year.
And some people die of a heart attack there because you know it's too much for
them to be on that little bridge that they have there,
that that extends past the edge of a canyon.
They put in a little Bridgeway so that you can go and look down.
People have heart attacks,
two people that have had heart attacks from that,
but the other guys are the ones trying to do selfies.
A fallen off fucking bridge and plummeting.
Right.
So you gotta think,
man,
if we had,
if we had a flat earth,
how many people would be visiting the edge off taking a selfie?
Man,
there's no,
you know,
come on.
No doubt.
There'd be teams of people,
teams,
they would travel to flat earth and they would,
they would like rope.
Apparently.
Like Alex Honnold would probably try to climb off the side.
We'd hear it on the news.
Another person has died from falling off the edge of the earth.
Yeah,
it would be 100% that'd be our hundredth flat out.
People would tell you though that the government guards that.
Yeah.
Not.
And are they right?
Yeah.
You can't go near it.
Pro.
Yeah.
Battleships.
Well there wouldn't be just one edge though,
right?
That's true there.
They didn't think that through.
Yeah.
No,
there'd be several ledges if we're flat.
Yeah.
But see,
you got to have that youtube mentality.
You've got to put your head in a little box,
leave it in their fucking,
turn the oven box on and stick your head in.
The government's plucking the edge,
man.
You can't get near it.
Yeah.
It's like we're living in a dome,
you know that's,
yeah,
the Dome,
the Dome theory because there's no space spaces.
Fake
man spoke to what people want to believe in some crazy shit.
You know.
I want to,
how much of them are stoners?
Like most of them,
right?
How many of them are microdosing?
Oh cool.
Yeah,
probably cause you know,
cause cause that's a thing now everybody's like fucking microdosing right now
and it's not bad for you.
They say it's actually kind of good for you,
but Ron White's doing it.
But on white microdose is a silicide man every day.
He has never felt better in my life.
And they like to talk when they're microdosing especially.
So Simon,
you just have these ideas.
That's the thing.
You have ideas in your mind becomes open to shit that normally,
you know,
you're closed off to obviously,
you know.
Yeah.
But you know,
I think they think that the earth is a disk.
I think that's what I've heard recently.
They think it's a disk,
a disk.
I'm sort of a floating disk and then we live in the firm admin or something like
that.
It was like some sort of a cover over the top of the desk and that's what the,
here it is.
What does this Jamie,
it's the cruise,
the cruise next year that the floods loose.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Is that the venture yet?
They're going to get to the fucking glaciers and they're gonna be word told you
the wool,
the flat earth through help.
They jump out and get eaten by a polar bear.
That's the funniest shit has to use gps to get around.
So I mean,
you know,
how many scientists do they have on their side?
Oh,
all of them.
That's the funniest shit.
No,
it's fucking ridiculous.
There's,
there's,
there's gigantic satellites that take huge high resolution photos of the earth.
Every 10 seconds orbit from thousands of miles out.
Those are doctored.
Yeah.
It's just the whole thing is so fucking stupid of all the shit to believe in,
to invest any energy in that.
Like why would someone lie about the shape of the earth?
That's the dumbest part about it.
You want to know what I think is,
is,
um,
before the Internet and all these different platforms where you can get
information,
they,
you know,
our government and other governments could debunk any information on Ufos,
anything.
Because they,
you know,
there wasn't like the wide communication that did exist now.
Right.
So I think now they put in people who are saying this crazy,
wild way out shit so that people are,
that are really trying to expose truth on certain things.
They get looked at as whack jobs like the rest of those that are trying to say,
oh,
well,
flat earth,
or we're on a disk or we're in a globe,
or blah,
blah,
blah.
You know,
I've been spying on you.
They'll throw all that together.
It is spying on you.
If they are,
that is for sure.
I mean,
they really are that it's,
it's,
you know,
since George Bush Jr was president,
they've been listening to our phone calls.
I mean,
that's a fact.
that was one of the,
the things they enacted with the homeland security,
that they can record every American's call and,
you know,
whatever conversation mentioned certain key words as we were saying earlier,
they would,
you know,
they would get shuffled off to a certain department and those guys were red
flagged and looked at and that still happens today still to this day.
You don't need a warrant.
They can just listen.
I mean,
I'll tell you this,
right?
There was a,
I've been traveling what,
20,
20 some odd years at,
at this
where,
um,
when I,
when I was coming back into to the United States for a long time,
I would not get randomly checked or anything like that.
They just let us go by and I made a few posts somewhere,
you know,
with an abundant amount of cannabis.
Right.
And right after that post,
each time I came back into the United States,
they send me into secondary for a search.
And I started asking like,
Hey,
I've been traveling for x amount of years.
Now every,
I've noticed that the last four times that have come back from another country,
you guys are randomly,
you know,
checking my bags now what's the deal in my red flag?
What's going on with my passport?
Um,
well,
you know,
we're not really allowed to tell you this,
but I mean,
have you been with kind of postings have you made on your social networks?
Really?
Yeah.
And I said,
okay,
say no more in our annuity.
It was,
cause I had put like,
you know,
a post with like four or five,
six pounds in it.
What is five pounds of weed even like,
like
giant pillows.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
right then and there I knew,
from that reaction that he had,
did anybody with any sort of,
um,
that's involved in entertainment,
music,
athlete,
you know,
whatever actor,
actress,
they're watching all of our shit.
Oh for sure they're listening and they're watching.
So someone like you who's been at the forefront of pushing cannabis legalization
and always talked about it openly,
flagrantly,
even when it was a schedule one substance.
So yeah.
Everywhere,
you know.
Yeah.
Did you get a medical card with here the year that it was available?
The first year it was available.
Was that like 95 or something?
94 they had got my from,
from doctor Idleman,
he was like one of the,
and hooked me up.
I don't have brothers.
All right.
A lot of us,
I used to go to him even when it was way more expensive cause I'm like,
oh gee,
yeah a bro.
He like he told me,
he goes,
my God,
cause cause I lost track of him for a minute,
you know.
And,
uh,
when I went back to get a renewal some years back and he's like,
Louis,
you've,
you've been with me a long time.
I mean,
is it what it looks like?
Is that your patient number four
number four on his first cause he keeps a list of all his patients,
I guess.
You know,
and apparently I was number four.
Yeah.
Even though there was doctors out here,
I'd always go travel to see him in Hollywood just out of respect.
And uh,
he always had these,
he had like,
Oh gee stoners in the waiting room.
Oh yes.
People that were just like barely holding on to reality.
Oh yeah.
He had,
he had all sorts,
he had the hippies.
He had the new,
new,
new Jen's hip hop people.
I had vitamin DRIPS and shit to all kinds of weird stuff in his office.
He would,
yeah,
he would try to sell you on some,
some different technology.
Anytime we can use this'll help you stop smoking cigarettes.
Well,
I don't smoke cigarettes.
He had like a thing you put on your ear trickle thing.
The electrode.
Yeah.
They gave one to red band.
It didn't work.
Yeah.
You know,
you got to try something,
right?
Yeah.
It was like a battery power thing.
Right.
I'd give a little charge to your ear that somehow knows supposed to stop you
from smoking cigarettes.
Like,
yeah,
I didn't get,
I didn't smoke cigarettes,
so it was like,
Eh,
I don't smoke cigarettes.
Did you ever get your lungs checked out from all those years of weed smoking?
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
you know,
I get physicals and stuff like that and uh,
occasionally I'll have my lungs checked and they tell me they're great.
Isn't that amazing?
It's crazy,
you know,
because I think if you keep active,
like you train and,
and,
uh,
a lot of us trained now,
like this generation,
they're not like lazy stoners.
They don't just sit back and do nothing.
There still are those.
But you know,
I don't think it has the same carcinogens is,
you know,
people expect it,
like cigarette.
It does.
And so,
you know,
you might look at someone's lungs who,
who,
who smoked cigarettes and,
and you might see something,
they're like,
hey,
you need to slow the fuck down over here.
But in,
in every time that I've had my lungs checked or whatever,
for whatever,
whether I've,
you know,
gotten sick or whatever,
they're always telling me lungs,
they're in good shape.
And it's a funny thing because,
you know,
and they can,
1987,
you know,
I was 17 and I was gang banging,
I got shot and you know,
that I got hit by a 22 and it is hollow points do it.
Um,
it,
it broke into three,
three pieces,
the hollow point.
And one of them pro punctured my lung on my left side.
And uh,
you know,
they were telling me,
well,
you know,
um,
do you smoke?
No,
I don't really smoke cause I didn't smoke cigarettes.
I smoked weed,
but I wasn't going to divulge that at the time.
I was 17 and you know,
and uh,
they said,
well,
you know,
well that's good because you'll never smoke again.
It was like you'd do,
they punctured her lung and blah,
blah,
blah.
They thought I was going to have to work off one lung,
but in the three days,
you know,
they were able to get the blood out of the lung and I was able to get it back,
through the exercises they told me,
you know,
to get it back to its regular size and I've never had a problem since then.
Knock on wood,
the piece of metal out.
No,
I still got the three pieces.
That's like when I go do my physicals and they do the,
you know,
the Mri,
the Mris and the x rays and all that.
The doctors,
you know,
sometimes they forget because they see so many patients.
Mr Freeze,
these appeared to be bullet fragments with,
what is that?
Well,
you just said it,
doctor,
bullet,
frack.
You've seen him a dozen times,
you know,
and uh,
yeah,
I was very lucky.
I was very lucky because,
you know,
punctured my lung.
And then two of the pieces,
one was by the heart and one was by my spine,
but I was at a Martin Luther King Hospital in Linwood.
And we call that place killer king because you go in there for something small
and ended up dying or come out,
you know,
get out or something.
So you know,
I wasn't going to allow them to try and get to those bullets or those fragments
to open you up.
Yeah,
no,
no.
Cause you know,
they didn't have a great success rate.
What kind of lung exercises they give you pumped your lungs,
but they give you this breathing apparatus that has like a ball in it,
right?
And it has two lines and you know,
it's the first line you're trying to,
they're telling you every day for five minutes,
10 minutes to blow that,
you know,
not all in one shot,
but like to keep practicing getting the ball up there and that will help inflate
the lung and get it back.
So I had to do that for probably like three weeks.
And uh,
you know,
in the puncture wound it healed itself pretty much.
And,
uh,
and the pieces are still in your lungs?
Not In the lung.
It went passed along.
It did shot passed along.
So,
you know,
it's uh,
I got a piece up here and one off to the side in the back.
Well when it's really cold due to the,
the,
the nerve damage,
I'll get like stinging like you know,
like when your,
when your hand falls asleep,
the little needles that,
I'll get that here and then,
and then back here where it entered,
they had to,
they had to cut right in between a rib here to stick the tube in to put the hose
into the lung to get the blood out of the lump.
Damn.
Yeah.
As you know,
I was living crazy before I got into the music.
The music saved my life pretty much.
Really?
Yeah.
How long were you gang banging for?
For,
for some years.
You know,
I started,
I started young,
I was probably 13 years old.
Whoa.
Banging and,
and,
uh,
I got out of it probably,
I didn't necessarily get out,
but I changed up what I was doing because you don't ever really get out per se
unless they jump you out and,
you know,
I was to intuit to,
to be jumped out like that.
You know what I mean?
That wasn't something I was going to do because,
you know,
for as negative as it was,
it taught me a lot.
Um,
so my,
my boys that I,
you know,
ran with,
they understood I was trying to do something different.
You know,
I made a choice to try the music and,
and leave that shit alone because there,
there was no way that you do both.
If you do both,
you see the results of that.
What's happening today with a lot of cats,
you know what I mean?
They tried to ride the line,
be professional and be in the music,
but they're still kind of in this world over here.
And when it bleeds in,
one bleeds into the other,
it,
you know,
it fucks everything up,
you know?
And,
uh,
so I chose,
you know,
I was going to do music and just talk about those life experiences and whatnot.
And that was probably at I'm 18 that a,
I started taking on the music and,
uh,
that's,
that's where it went.
You know,
like when you said you learned a lot from it,
like what did you learn from it?
Well,
you know,
your street,
there's,
there's common sense and then there's common sense on the streets and then
there's being aware and looking out and you know,
not being a doormat and,
uh,
just it's,
it's a whole different type of schooling when you're gang banging,
you know,
that's the way you carry yourself,
the way you communicate with someone and know whether they're disrespecting you
or not and how you deal with that disrespect,
which is,
you know,
a whole different world in the gang bang shit.
But it's a,
it's a different kind of education.
You know,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't take it back.
Some of the things I would,
you know,
I definitely regretted while I was doing it for sure.
But,
um,
it made me see things from,
from a different perspective,
you know,
and,
and why,
you know,
things are the way they are in gangs and stuff like that from lack,
lack of opportunities,
you know,
for,
for these kids to be doing something,
you know,
cause not everybody's good at sports,
but there has to be other opportunities other than other than that to get kids
interested in doing something else because falling into the gangs,
it's,
it's easy if you don't have a good home life at home.
The guys on the street are your second family and they eventually become your
first family.
You know what I mean?
And if you don't have a father figure at home,
one of the guys in the gang,
you know,
becomes your mentor,
he could become like the guy you look up to as like your father figure.
You know,
there's that.
And then,
you know,
again,
there's not enough programs out there to keep people into doing something
different than falling into that.
And then sometimes,
you know,
it just,
it's a matter of,
you know,
you growing up in this neighborhood,
if you have to walk down that street and they approach you and say,
Hey,
you live in this hood,
you got to be with us.
If you don't,
we're going to make it hard for you.
So there's that peer pressure and then there's the legacy shit.
Like,
so of my father was a gangster in this gang and he still lives in this
neighborhood.
Pressure's on for me eventually to take up where father left off,
you know?
And uh,
it's,
it's all those things and that some people just start thrill seekers and they
choose it and have nothing,
you know,
in common with none of that.
They just choose it for some people too.
It's so appealing to have somewhere that you belong right in.
And that's the thing,
because if you don't feel like you belong in your school or you don't with your
in your family and,
and that,
that she can totally take hold in,
in,
you end up there.
You know,
fortunately I had good friends that weren't gang bangers.
that they had talent for music,
which is mugs and sin.
And since brother mellow,
you know,
they were,
I did music as a hobby,
you know,
before I got into gangs and they got me back into the music.
They cause they recognize something in me and said,
hey,
we want you to come back where we got these opportunities over here.
Come join us.
Did you always have that style?
No,
I didn't.
One that you developed that once we started working on our Cypress Hill Demos,
um,
mugs came to me and said,
hey man,
you gotta do something gotta do something different.
Otherwise you're going to write for sin.
Because sin had a good voice.
His shit was locked in my voice as wrapping in a voice similar to the one and
talking and all of the rhymes were good.
It didn't cut through on the style,
like on,
on,
you know,
on the beats.
It just sounded like,
you know,
some regular shit.
So,
you know,
I didn't want to be someone's writer,
I wanted to write for myself.
So you know,
there was a guy that we used to listen to,
um,
coming up was name is Ram Lz.
He was on this a record called wild style and he was in the movie,
he was this rapper who is very obscure,
but he was a artist too,
you know,
like a graffiti artists but then also an artist artist,
but he was also a rapper and when he would do is he'd wrap into regular style,
like his talking voice.
This is the brother they called the rebel.
He had a deep voice like that and then he would flip right in the middle,
take it up town to Cypress Hill with the shot gun,
Baba like that.
And you know,
we were always freaking out on it yet two styles.
So I tried throwing my voice in that sort of similar style and it ended up
sticking.
I didn't really like,
I didn't think anybody was going to like it.
I thought they were going to be like,
get the fuck Outta here with that.
But they ended up liking it.
And,
uh,
I think the first song that,
um,
came about in that style was the song real estate off our first album.
It's a,
you know,
that was where I tried it the first time.
They liked it.
So then kill a man came next to [inaudible] that song and that style then hand
on the pump and it just became a flow after that.
And I really did not feel it at first.
I was like,
fuck,
I can't believe they got me rapping in this voice.
And it,
it took,
it took a minute to get used to that,
you know,
like doing it live because,
I had a tendency as,
as rappers,
you know,
that don't know because there's no school for this unless you have somebody
who's done it and they teach you,
okay,
this is what the get down is.
And we didn't have that really.
It was all hands on learning.
I,
you know,
for the first few years of man,
I was trying to do the voice and I'd ended up,
you know,
getting over hyped because the crowd is hyping that start yelling the versus
instead of like wrapping them,
like on the record I'd throw my voice out,
my voice would get scratchy,
I'd be sounded like Busta rhymes and shit.
You know what I mean?
And it took me five years to actually harness how to actually do the shows with
this voice.
And I had to go to this opera singer,
um,
coach really the name was something Elizabeth Sabine or something like that.
She trained a lot of folks but she,
she,
her shit was like to teach you the operatic way of,
of singing,
which is from the diaphragm,
tightened the stomach,
take little breaths.
But those little breaths make your lungs expand,
you know,
a lot and it's less projection from your throat and more from the bottom.
And she taught me that technique and I never went horse again after that.
I like with,
you know,
people often compliment me on,
sounding so close to how the records are.
There's once in a while where I might get excited and start saying it louder
than it might be,
but I'm always sorta right there and I got it.
You know,
I got to give all props to her because if she hadn't showed me that technique,
I'd probably still be yelling and screaming my shit out,
locking up my voice.
You know,
that brings up an interesting point is this her metal right here.
Wait,
let me hear some cold.
We can't play this on youtube.
We'll get kicked off.
And she was,
and she was an opera singer at one time,
but she went on to teach people the technique.
No kid in man.
That is why.
See,
because if you try to keep your breath and in sustain a long note like that from
your chest,
you won't sustain that note long enough.
But if you tight now from your diaphragm,
yeah.
If you tighten up almost,
it's almost like if you're going to take a shit
oh,
instead of from the throat.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
You know,
like it,
it allows you,
it allows your lungs to expand while you're breathing from your diaphragm.
So that's what she taught a lot of singers.
And it's a,
another method is to cheat the word,
like pronounce it,
you know,
like you're kind of like,
it's,
it's like what these mumble rappers do when they pronounce a word and they kind
of mumble it and the sort of cheat it,
you know what the word is,
but they didn't pronounce it all the way.
So,
so in other words,
if she's going to you,
we're going to sing the line,
come,
he come with me.
So it sounds a little bit cleaner.
You'd say gum with me,
but in the way you would say it is more with a g,
but it's so tucked in that you here come with me and it's just a cheating way of
saying it to get the line a little bit cleaner and fucking,
uh,
you know,
and the breath.
And she taught me all that shit.
And,
and,
and it worked for rap.
I didn't know if it would because I mean,
it was,
it's the sheep primarily taught singers.
I was probably the first rapper that she taught this technique too.
And it stuck,
man.
How'd you find her?
Um,
what am,
what am I friends had heard of her?
You know,
because I mean,
in the,
in the industry,
you know,
become friends with other,
um,
your peers and stuff like that,
you know,
I knew a couple of singers and they,
they,
they were,
you know,
noting my problem is to,
screaming my versus in coming back with the raspy voice.
So they were like,
here,
why don't you try this person right here?
This person taught or,
or gave this technique to so and so.
And it was another singer.
I can't remember.
But,
um,
I thought,
well,
you know,
what have I got to lose?
I mean,
if it doesn't work,
it doesn't work,
but it may be,
I learned something from it that I could use somewhere else.
Right.
And Fuck,
she,
she taught me the warmup.
She taught me.
Uh,
you know,
the certain words that you can cheat to,
to,
you know,
for,
for certain breath control purposes cause the way you pronounce certain things,
you know,
sort of add to that and just the tightening of the diaphragm man.
Like if,
if I hadn't learned that it would have took me a lot longer to do the shows the
way that I can do them now.
So do you warm up before shows?
I don't necessarily need to like from the first song on my voice like gets in
like the first few bars.
It,
it warms up right then and there and uh,
it's not really like singing where I got a sustained notes and stuff like that
so I don't have to do those same kind of warm ups.
If I was going to sing some shit,
yes,
I would definitely have to get my,
you know,
get the pitch right and the throat warmed up to,
to do those different,
you know,
melodies or whatever the hell.
But fortunately I don't sing though.
The whole rap world has always been fascinating to me.
Like how someone gets in,
like,
how do you get started?
Are there open mics?
Like what?
[inaudible] back in the day,
man,
someone had to be the guy endorsing you.
You know,
like saying to,
you know these guys over here,
Amen.
Listen to this,
these artists,
right?
Or this artist right here,
they're the new shit.
They're going to be the one and then you would have to do a couple of showcases
and stuff like that.
And you know,
when some people over,
I mean we,
we definitely did our share of showcases in the beginning,
but we were getting passed on left and right.
Because,
you know,
people thought,
what are they talking about with this cannabis shit?
And we,
and we didn't sound like a west coast group,
you know,
because we were trying to sell our shit to west coast labels here and they did
not get us.
It wasn't until,
you know,
um,
mugs had had,
you know,
he'd previously been in a group called [inaudible] 73 and he had worked with
these guys called the rhyme syndicate,
which was ice teas guy.
So he kind of,
you know,
he was the guy that people knew and then,
um,
send dogs,
brother and mellow man,
ace eventually would get in the door.
And so people started hearing about us through,
you know,
through more mugs and mellow metal.
Mellow didn't really do shit for us,
you know,
I'll,
I'll truth told,
but mugs,
you know,
they kept hearing about a group that he was forming outside of 73,
which came to be Cypress Hill.
And so,
you know,
the guys that worked on him worked with him on the 73 records,
which is Joe's Niccolo of,
of rough house records,
you know,
he wanted to sign whatever Muggs was doing and you know,
he eventually ended up signing us.
Um,
and they had a distribution deal with a,
with Sony music.
So,
you know,
we,
put out our records of rough house Columbia or roughhouse,
Sony,
something like that.
And that's how we got put on,
you know,
and,
and again,
it had to be word of mouth because if nobody heard it,
you heard of you.
You had to have some really fucking dope music for them to even like consider
you if you didn't have like someone back in you.
It was tough.
You know,
you had to have someone come speak on your behalf and say,
hey these guys are the new new shit.
And,
and uh,
fortunately for us,
once we put out our snippet tape,
like when Sony put out our snippet tape,
guys like EPMD right.
And they were one of our favorite groups in the world,
man.
It would the top five for Cypress others,
you know,
public enemy,
Beastie boys EPMD fuck.
They were the shit.
And uh,
those were the guys that took our snippet tape and they were showing our snippet
tape to other rappers.
Like,
hey guys,
look at these new fucking guys.
Cause you know,
Busta rhyme told me this story you'll love,
you'll are just shift from EPMD way back in the day they was planning for a
public enemy and I just happened to be in the room and Wa and you know,
ice cube when we met him for the first time,
you know,
um,
and we had our ups and downs with him,
but he's one of my homeys.
Um,
he,
he told me,
yeah man,
the first time I heard of y'all was through epmt that we was on tour was doing
the show and they came in,
which I'll tape and that's how I heard of y'all.
And,
and you know,
they were like our first street team,
man,
fucking evil.
Our faith,
our favorite,
one of our top three favorite groups was out there,
like with our snippet tape telling people,
hey,
these guys are the new shit.
And uh,
they do,
they do stuff occasionally,
but,
uh,
they,
I think they do more work,
you know,
individually.
Now I know Eric sermon is putting out a record right now.
He was just promoting it on,
on some radio show.
And,
uh,
I mean those guys still active,
stay active.
I mean he's a producer so he's always making music.
But as a rapper,
you know,
they don't put out as much stuff as they used to.
But yeah,
they're still active.
You know who I Miss Kool g rap,
Kool g rap.
I still passed out a,
a lot of guys don't have a style if he doesn't,
you know,
if he had never come out of so many people were influenced by him.
Yeah.
Bad motherfuckers.
A lot of people forgot about him.
A lot of people forgot about him and he was one of the baddest dudes I'd been a
lot of people you know,
would talk about big daddy Kane and Rakim.
Sure.
But you couldn't talk about them without talking about Kool g rap cause he was
like one of those guys like spitting med versus man,
like his bar work was incredible.
He was incredible.
I still listened to that song.
Cock blocking.
Every now and then I'll throw that on and I gotta tell you,
you know,
like if you hear songs that he does today,
he is still fucking current.
Like his,
he's still got that style that that cuts through.
Like,
you know,
some of the older artists,
they sort of lose the style that people love and they don't know how to
transition into,
you know,
what their style would be right now.
You know,
like updating whatever that style is.
a lot of,
a lot of the older artists had troubles doing that,
you know,
but my main Kool g rap,
not a fucking street blues.
Well he's still ill.
Tastic yeah,
yeah.
I always got confused why he didn't get bigger.
I didn't get it.
I was like,
he's got so good.
You know,
I think it was,
it was just the wave that came after him.
You know,
it's,
it's like,
uh,
he was such an underground force and if you're underground force,
you know,
you had to make a conscious decision whether,
okay,
I'm going to go,
man,
if I go mainstream,
I'm going to lose these hardcore fans.
I might gain,
you know,
these mainstream fans.
But how long are they going to stay with me as opposed to these core fans that
you know,
that they're there.
But with his style,
he couldn't just keep them because I thought he could.
I think guys kept him.
Right.
You want to know something.
I think it was due to,
um,
you know,
the record company not wanting to take the chance because as an artist you want
everybody to hear your shit.
You know,
for us,
we didn't play those games.
We said fuck it.
You know,
if,
if we felt it was the right look for us,
we were going to take it,
you know,
no matter what anybody thought,
and,
uh,
again,
you faced scrutiny for Shit like that,
but in the end,
you know,
if you didn't play yourself,
people remember that,
you know,
and we said,
fuck it.
We're going to take our music mainstream.
Even though that was not our intent.
You know,
we always meant ourselves to be a more underground group,
but insane.
And the brand didn't allow that.
Uh,
it,
it propelled us,
you know,
so we were like,
okay,
well we're going to take our underground assets up into this mainstream and show
him how we do it.
And it,
it kicked the door open for a lot of an other underground acts to go into the
mainstream.
And we prove that if you do it right and if stay on your game and if you keep
working in,
in and stay present and put out quality music that you can sustain those,
those mainstream fas that you gain right there and the core.
Yeah.
You guys sustain so well that people covered your shit.
Yeah,
like rage.
That was awesome.
She,
when they covered pistol grip pump on my left at all times.
Holy Shit.
One of my favorite bands,
still a roach,
a yell that,
that,
that shit was awesome.
I mean he took a totally different take on it but like a cover.
But it was,
it was a cover but it was his take.
Yeah,
it was bad at it.
It was one of my favorites,
man.
You know,
and it was a honor to me because you know,
like I was really good friends with them to begin with.
I saw them come out the gate before they exploded and became rage against the
machine.
And so for them to cover,
one of our songs were like,
man,
fuck yeah.
You know,
because they,
they,
they helped us get better.
You know,
there was a lot of groups that we look to influence even if they were doing
different style of music,
like public enemy wasn't influenced to us.
Rage against the machine was an inspiration to us to like push the envelope a
little bit more on what we were doing.
Not necessarily like how they were because they had their own sound just like we
had our own sound.
So they made us push,
you know,
in groups like that made us better.
So when we heard this guy fucking doing or this Ben doing the cover and then
they asked us to come play this song,
which,
which would be their last night as rage against the machine for a long time.
This was like their last show right here.
We got to do that with them and I must,
must've been amazing.
And I was wearing a dad hat before,
dad hats were cool.
I will not wear one right now,
however I know what I was thinking.
But fuck it.
I'm there.
Yes.
Areas.
It was a fun show,
man.
I went into the mosh pit,
but Israel before that song,
before they called us up for that song,
for most of their set,
I was in the mosh pit and there was you,
you,
USC,
uh,
front lineman down their record shop,
Bro.
How's it in there with them?
They were protected me.
I was like,
Oh shit.
Be Real.
You're up in that.
We're working.
Shopped together.
It was,
it was awesome.
This is a video of Dana white in a mosh pit once.
I don't know what the fuck he was thinking.
He must have been drunk.
He jumped in the mosh pit like years ago.
He's a big dude though.
He's a big dude.
He's jumping around their motion around.
Yeah.
I dated a girl,
got Kale in a mosh pit once a man.
It's crazy,
man.
I used to go into a lot of different mosh pits are there.
He's in the rage mush,
but the rates of it is safe.
But every now and then you're running into a dick head.
I'll tell you man,
the craziest mosh pits,
you know,
that I saw,
well the craziest mosh pits I've gotten into,
there was a limp biscuit mosh pit.
That was crazy.
And,
but the craziest was was the rage mosh pit.
But the ones that I seen from outside of it not being in it that were crazy was
there was a sound garden mosh pit.
The next zoom garden.
Yeah.
At,
at Lollapalooza early on it was,
uh,
when they had bad motor finger out.
Oh Man.
That fucking mosh pit was like,
oh,
whirlpool of chaos bro.
I was loving it.
And that was on mushrooms watching this shit.
So it was fucking amazing.
And uh,
then,
uh,
and then a slayer mosh pit man,
they're fucking shit is brutal.
Yeah,
that sounds like just the pace of slayer.
It's crazy.
But I got to tell you,
since joining profits of rage in us,
you know,
when we tour Europe and stuff like that,
and we do a combination of,
you know,
uh,
rage against the machine songs,
public enemy and Cypress Hill,
along with our,
our own material.
The mosh pits are fucking crazy,
man.
But you know,
there was one,
one,
one thing that I saw that was not brutal,
but it was cool as fuck.
And it was in,
um,
I think,
I believe it was Sweden or Switzerland,
but they're,
you know,
out of like the 60,
70,000 people that were out there,
there was like maybe 5,000 concentrated people who sat down on their ass.
Right.
And we're like,
the fuck are these people doing aren't like,
are they protesting?
Are Separate.
Fuck is going on.
Right.
And what was crazy as you know,
you're not going to stop playing.
You just keep going.
So we start on,
on,
um,
I believe the song was good,
real gorilla radio that we were planted,
that,
that point.
All of a sudden we see them start doing this.
The Rowan,
they were wrote,
it was like a viking row.
It was fucking move.
It was a move that the crowd was doing.
So there's five,
5,000 people out of the 30,000 that are sitting in,
you know,
like next to each other lines,
rows,
you know,
just fucking of people rowing on beat dog.
It was the fucking vikings man.
How crazy.
That DNA just stuck with those people.
And that was just the little section of it,
man.
If you were to see from stage,
Daryl was like,
it was spot like spotted groups and they sat down and they sat down and were
rowing
so fucking crazy.
Yeah.
Have you ever seen the,
there was a,
they did a viking chant once at a soccer game.
Crazy.
Aw Man.
It's wild because the whole fucking arena did it and you feel it.
You feel that shit.
You gotta think man,
when they were going to wars back in the day and they rallied all their guys up
just like that,
that the fucking row out of tune though.
This fucking bolt's going to go sideways.
You don't,
I don't,
I don't know where that move comes from,
but it looks cool when you seal as fuck.
That's gotta be an old school viking thing.
Yeah,
they probably do it when they get drunk.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
think about it.
You know they used to conquest motherfuckers so they're like fucking row and
throw it in row.
Imagine here it like,
see if you can find that the Viking one at a soccer game.
Cause it's like,
I think it's at a world or something like that.
But
they like,
Ooh,
you hear it in the crowd and he's like,
oh my God.
Imagine hearing that shit over the,
when they're coming to get you to cause your village like grabbed the baby.
We're going to live in the woods.
Fuck you.
Gotta get Outta here.
Yeah.
And those are big
dudes.
Yeah,
there it is.
Oh yeah.
Look at that dog tuned weatherman.
They're all insane.
Look at the hand.
That's spooky.
Yeah.
Met is a fuckers.
Somebody reignites them.
Imagine that component is coming over the world.
There's enough of them.
That's it.
Madison,
that Hoard Cup.
And that's fucking crazy line of DNA.
You know a line of people that just were conquerors,
sturdy motherfuckers,
sturdy giant motherfuckers who did mushrooms.
Yeah,
they would,
they would blaze up mushroom,
their fucking heads into oblivion and you just go slash people get them.
It's crazy,
man.
This is another one sitting.
Another one.
So that's like the
Viking clip,
I guess the NFL biking sort of adopted this recently and they do it in their
football game.
Yeah.
But look at that Dork with the glasses.
Put Your fucking hands down,
man.
Stop.
That's in Brown Viking.
The chat to figure out to beat you stopped that.
Sorry look.
He's like,
well are you,
she'll highlight get it.
He's a spiking.
So when when you first start rapping,
like you wrapped them with kids in your neighborhood or you like aspiring to be
a rapper and writing shit down and try and things on your friends.
Like how do you get started?
Well,
the way that I started,
I was writing,
you know,
like poetry first.
Really?
Yeah.
What kind of poetry?
Just like,
you know,
like hoods,
stuff,
you know,
just stuff that rhymed.
But like just sort of writing it down.
Like it was a,
it was almost like writing raps,
but it just,
you know,
it's without saying it right,
because you read it and shit like that,
whatever.
But I would just write poetry about,
you know,
everyday shit.
You know what I mean?
Nothing,
you know.
It wasn't like doing like the,
I don't know if there's like categories of poetry,
but it,
you know,
it was just stuff that that would happen from day to day,
and uh,
I had a knack for writing and I realize that now is wanted to be a journalist.
That's what really the thing that I thought I was going to be at school.
Right.
Do you right now,
uh,
I was for a while,
but I looked at him and stuff just again everyday stuff or you know,
I'd like randomly pick something to write about.
So if it was Ken about the cannabis industry,
I'd write something about that.
If it was about the music industry,
Like I that every now and then I would,
uh,
there was,
back in the early two thousands,
there was a magazine called industry insider magazine.
And occasionally I would write articles for that.
I wasn't
really that great because,
you know,
I was so spotty and school that,
my,
you know,
it needed work,
but they left it raw the way that,
that,
that I would put it out there and people got my point and that,
that was cool.
But I looked at it in the way that the,
the music that I've done in a lot of the songs serve as a certain form of
journal journalism for me.
You know,
like,
you know,
bringing up certain issues that people don't necessarily hear.
Like throw your set in the air as a song on temple's boom.
And it's a song about how you would get,
you know,
in,
in inducted into a gang,
how you get put into a gang,
how you fall into it.
And some people might think,
you know,
by hearing it that it was glorifying it and praising it,
but it wasn't,
it was basically this is how it is.
This is so,
you know,
the signs to look for if your kids are,
fucking around with the wrong people,
you know?
And that's,
you know,
I took it like,
okay,
you know,
maybe I'm not a journalist,
like I tended to be,
but this is my way of it.
You know,
I can enlighten people with certain things and uh,
you know,
like anything,
somebody's going to read something or hear something and maybe misinterpret what
you say.
But you know,
it's all about who's who's listening and who's reading and who's watching and
stuff like that and their interpretation of it.
And some get it,
some don't.
And that's just the nature of it.
But like,
most people get it.
And I've,
I've come across people that have come to me and come and said,
hey man,
your,
your songs on temple of boom men.
You know,
they,
they helped to get me through these times or these songs raised me,
they taught me this,
this and that.
That's awesome.
And to me,
you know,
that,
that's,
that's the impact right there.
That's the shit yeah.
Means more than anything.
Because I'm sure you remember songs that got you through,
right?
Oh yeah,
for sure.
You know,
there was songs from Krs one public enemy that,
you know,
got me through and fired me up,
and inspired and stuff like that.
Era's ones,
another one people forgot about,
man,
I'll be in my car just going,
Ooh,
that's nice.
Yeah.
I mean he,
he taught,
he taught me how to be a bull horn,
you know what I mean?
Like tell you know,
like yeah,
tell the truth,
you know,
yours tell,
get the word out and,
and,
and not be fearful of what might happen because he could have been one of the
biggest stars in,
in hip hop.
He chose not to be,
he chose to be a voice and sometimes and be in that voice,
you know,
you get objects put in front of you and uh,
certain opportunities don't,
you know,
get put on your table because he says some great shit,
man.
He's talking about getting mad at the president.
It's like being mad at the manager at McDonald's.
Yeah.
You know,
for the way the corporations being run.
Yeah.
It's,
it's he,
he is a very insightful in,
in the shit that he says and he is very unafraid to state it in state.
His opinion,
if you to get like people coming up to you when they first started coming up to
you,
telling you that your music got them through things,
that it means so much to them.
When that first started happening,
that must've been surreal,
you know?
Yeah.
Because as an artist,
as especially as a young artist,
you'd,
that's not something you think about.
All of these songs are going to,
well it depends on,
on the artist you are right guys hit.
How old were you?
Like 23 or something like that.
How old were you when that was like a,
we released in 91 and it really started going for us in 92 saws.
22 you're a kid.
So crazy.
There goes the baby fro.
Wow.
Look at the baby fro.
But I mean,
think about that man.
That is so crazy for you to go from the guy who yo MTV raps.
Who remembers that?
I did a bungee jump at this spring break with treach from naughty by nature.
Was that the one that was in Cancun?
No,
that was Daytona beach.
Right,
okay.
When MTV was still,
when MTV was still allowed over there,
it was back when MTV had music.
Yeah.
When they had music format empty was MTV was music videos.
Good luck finding a fucking music video.
Now
I've got to go to youtube.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Wow.
That is wild.
What was it like when it first started popping off and you were 22 years old?
Was it,
did it feel real?
It was a,
it was a crazy thing because it's not something that I had ever envisioned
happening.
You know,
I didn't think that,
you know,
the music would blow up like that.
You know,
we were doing it to obviously try and,
and,
and make a name for ourselves and,
and uh,
make music that people like,
but fuck,
we didn't see that coming in,
especially with insane in the brain when they told me,
uh,
when like when killer man started going,
it was like surreal because,
you know,
we didn't think that song would take just because it,
of,
of the chorus itself,
you know,
fuck what the song is about.
You know,
we knew that the chorus was,
you know,
what,
they were going to hear more than anything.
And so I,
you know,
we,
we thought,
no,
we're going to have a good underground album.
We didn't realize that it blow up.
We didn't think they were going to put kill a man in the juice movie and that
would blow that song up even more so than it was it was getting,
um,
because we had released funky fill ones first and it was a Aa side single funky
fill in and kill a man on the other a side,
which means,
um,
at that time that Djs had the option of which song they wanted to go.
Whereas most of the time you had a side B side in the ace side is most
definitely the one that the record company wants you to push.
We gave it a Aa side because we thought maybe the djs would like kill a man
more.
They went with funky fill when the record company because they figured it would
be easier to market.
Right.
And then the DJ started the record chorus and we started getting traction behind
that.
Our record was out like six months had dropped off the chart and they flipped
the record.
Our shit slowly starts to go back up the chart.
We got back on the chart and started climbing and we were getting a whole lot of
mixed show play and uh,
then we start doing a lot of promotional shows that being one of them.
And it started going and killing men started getting us going.
And uh,
I mean we toured for probably a year and a half,
like a lot,
just a lot of promotional shows,
not getting paid,
you know,
just,
Sony having us out there promoting the record and then by the time,
uh,
you know,
our record got back back up into the middle of the charts.
I mean,
it was still rising,
but,
and they saw that they were like,
we got to get them off the road and making a new record.
So that's when we got out there with black Sunday and a with black Sunday and
insane coming out again.
That's not a song.
I thought it would blow up when they've chose that for the single,
I'm like,
well,
all right,
there's better songs,
but fuck it.
That's the one.
Okay.
So it comes out,
boom,
it explodes.
And now we have our black Sunday charting.
At number one coming in and our,
our first album had come all the way from the bottom to hit number five.
So we had to two albums in the top 10,
200 top 10 of the 200 songs,
you know,
on the chart,
which no one had ever done in hip hop before.
We had one in five slot and uh,
you know,
fuck,
we definitely didn't think that was going to happen.
I mean,
you know,
it was all a surprise and it went from one minute you could go to a mall and be,
unassuming and nobody even knows who the fuck you are and you know,
you're getting about your day to now you go to the mall and the whole fucking
mall is swarming on you.
Like fucking,
you're like,
you know,
Paul Mccartney or something.
It was the craziest shit they would ask us to leave the mall's like really?
Yeah,
like uh,
we used to,
I used to go to this one called the Montebello Mo.
It was in Montebello.
I can't remember what the name of the mall was,
but it was in Montebello.
The only one down there at the time.
And we knew everybody there,
you know,
as we're coming up because that's where we'd go shop.
So you know,
you make friends and people in the shop and stuff like that.
And uh,
when we come back off the tour this time and go try to go to that mall,
you know,
one of our friends fucked up and wore a Cypress hill jacket and that's like a
fucking billboard when you're standing next to one of us.
Right.
So before you know it,
boom,
we get swooped in and you know as a pre cell phone too.
Yeah.
And the mall security cause hey man,
you know,
I know it's fucked up,
but you guys got to go.
Really?
Yeah Man,
it's a commotion.
You guys got to go.
They're telling me,
I'm like,
they think someone's going to fight.
I'm wow.
I never went back to that mall after that.
Alright,
cool.
Because you know,
when I didn't want to cause them problems too,
it was now it was tough to go somewhere at that time and not get,
you know,
swarmed and that get swarmed.
Yeah.
It was,
it was,
uh,
it was quite,
quite,
uh,
an experience man.
Like,
you know,
cause you only ever hear about it until it happens.
And you might,
you know,
if you have friends in the,
in the industry and it's happening for them,
you might see it in directly,
you know,
like through the,
through their shit.
And uh,
you know,
we had friends in the business,
kid frost was one of my friends,
um,
before we got out there and cause he's still around.
Yeah.
He still does stuff,
you know.
Um,
I don't know if he's putting out so much new music these days,
but he's still here and there.
He's doing some of the cannabis industry stuff too because he's a big kind of
sore.
I got to tell you,
my man smokes used to smoke like a train man,
like him and I would trade joints off left and right.
But you know,
for a time,
you know,
I would go hang with him at his gigs.
I'd be his bodyguard cause I was the one that was not afraid to carry the
hammer,
meaning the magnum in my waistline.
You know,
I was,
we were cowboys,
man.
We,
we were always armed at that time,
from 89 to probably 97 or 98,
we were holding pistols on our hip,
like cowboys.
And,
you know,
he knew that.
So yes.
But he would ask me to go to the gigs,
you know,
to,
double as his body guard.
I wasn't his body guard,
but I was his body guard.
You know what I mean?
And I'd see the way he handled it and let's see the way,
you know,
people crowded around him and,
and uh,
you know,
I saw,
I learned how to deal with it,
watching,
you know,
how he would do it in a negative way or a positive way.
Cause,
you know,
he was sometimes embrace the crowds.
Sometimes it's like,
fuck off me.
You know,
like a lot a lot of artists are,
you know,
and uh,
that sort of prepared me so that when,
you know,
we got an arf lane,
I knew how to sort of deal with it and I,
you know,
was always courteous and,
and cool and respectful and never the guy that is like,
Nah man,
fuck that.
Get out of here.
Cause I see it in some of my homies were like that,
you know,
and I didn't,
I hated the feeling that when the fans would walk away,
just totally fucking wind out of their sails and shit like that.
Now they don't like this artists ever again,
you know?
And I saw that and I never wanted to have anyone walk away with that experience.
Always embraced it even when it was a pain in the ass,
you know?
So when was your first time ever getting onstage?
Do you remember first time that they used to be a club called radiotron here in
the 80s right.
And it was the hip hop club.
If you were into hip hop,
any aspect of it,
whether it was wrapping,
dancing,
popping,
graffitiing all the people went to that spot and um,
it was hard to get in there and it was hard to get on the mic no less.
Um,
but we had a homie who was like a legendary Dj out here when,
when,
uh,
the am station was playing hip hop,
his name was Tony g and he was,
uh,
the,
the leader of the mix master show.
They had mixed master and he had a residency at the radio tron.
So we grew up with one of his,
um,
when his boys,
that was his,
like his a protege.
So they invited us over and myself in San got on the mic and mellow and I froze
the fuck.
I tell you,
I froze up.
I forgot every rap I ever wrote or ever memorized.
I was like,
uh,
it would be one of the two times that I would freeze in my life.
And,
and it was,
that was the first time I was on stage and all those people looking at me
waiting,
expecting something.
I totally blew it.
You know,
and I told myself,
okay,
I got to get over the nervousness.
And then the other thing we were doing was,
uh,
it was like,
um,
they,
they wanted rappers to do this PSA for some bullshit,
right?
And they wanted us to write this wrap and put all this certain information in
there.
And I had it,
I had it memorized.
I hadn't locked in the minute they said go and they were filming it,
you know,
this is to film it.
I kept fucking it up horribly.
I didn't even get through it.
I was like,
I'm sorry I can't do it.
Fuck,
you know,
I was getting mad at myself too.
Like,
fuck,
what's wrong with me?
No,
it wasn't.
Maybe that was a problem.
That was probably the problem,
you know,
cause when I'm not high as when it's shit like this happens,
right?
So those are the two times that I totally fucked it up.
And I like from the last time I said,
I'll never do that again.
I'm going to be prepared and I'm going to get through the anxiety or whatever it
is.
And,
um,
so those were the first two times,
but the first time on stage where I actually pulled it off was probably one of
our first showcases.
It was that,
uh,
it was at this place off of the 10,
and it wasn't a showcase,
it was actually a competition.
You know how they used to do competitions?
It's clubs like fucking uh,
what do they call it?
A,
forgot what they used to call them,
but you know,
different bands with,
it was like a battle of the bands,
right?
So we went in and I'm coming off of that horrible fucking deal that had just
happened,
you know,
maybe a month or two before.
And I totally got over it and,
and we were performing real estate,
you know,
in this showcase and we lost.
But we made the biggest impression there because the song,
you know,
we performed it like,
the way that it supposed to be.
And then at the end,
sen out jumped on the big judges' table and he,
you know,
he grabbed
his balls right in front of the fucking female judge as he jumps off the table.
It breaks in half into her lap and
everybody loved it.
We lost to these dudes who are like new,
a new edition to,
we called them tootsie rolls,
but we don't remember they won.
But in reality we want,
because that's what everybody was talking about us at the end,
you know,
like how raw that wasn't.
After that show I realized,
you know,
this is,
this is how I'm supposed to do it.
And I seen Krs one,
uh,
do a show one time where the sound went out.
He didn't have a stage that he was on a couple of tables that were put together
and he just got up in front of the whole club,
no microphone,
no music,
and just started rapping his versus,
and people were rapping right along with them not giving a fuck that the sound
turned off,
but the fact that he just continued to do the show and that right there taught
me a lot about how you control shit on stage.
Yeah.
Sometimes on when things go wrong,
it's a great opportunity.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I did a show at the Improv last month,
like maybe my last month or the month before the power went out.
And then like a,
what do you want to do?
I said,
fuck it.
Let's do a show.
I could yell.
Yeah.
So we just did.
Everybody just did the show would no microphone.
But that was,
you know,
the Improv,
the small room.
It's only 180 people.
Yeah.
I mean that,
that place was,
you know,
a small place too.
But I mean it,
it goes to show you man,
like if you got it,
you got to do it.
It's probably better sometimes because it's unique.
Yeah.
Cause people will remember,
you know,
the other way.
Yeah.
You know,
it probably would have been a great show and people would be talking about it,
but they'll remember the fact that you got over that adversity and we're able to
still deliver.
And that's the shit that krs one did for me.
He showed me through the adversity,
he kept doing the show and the people were still with them.
And I thought,
okay,
one day that's going to be me and I'm going to do what the teacher does.
And,
uh,
you know,
that,
that had been one of the most important things that I learned,
you know,
and watching others do shows and stuff like that and what I would do when I got
up there,
you know,
and,
uh,
I,
I applied all those,
those,
you know,
lessons men,
and,
and it's made me who I am as my part of Cypress Hill and when I do my solo stuff
and when I'm with prophets of rage that,
you know,
that got me prepped for everything that I do now in terms of music now,
how did you,
well,
it's good that to you free to tell people that you had a real hard time your
first time performing.
Oh yeah.
There's probably a lot of people out there.
They'll never say anxious and yeah,
a lot of people never say that the lie,
you know?
But that's,
I think that's important and there's nothing wrong with those feelings,
man.
It's,
it's good you got to learn,
man.
You're a kid.
It's,
it's,
it's like,
uh,
you liking it to,
to like college stars that are coming into the professional sports now.
Like basketball players for instance.
You get this number one draft pick,
he comes to a team and everybody has these high expectations.
No one knows that this kid,
you know,
some people own this space like Lebron and Kolby and Kevin Garnett who've came
straight from high school and they own the space.
The minute they got in it.
I mean,
Colby had to work,
he wasn't the greatest,
you know,
when he,
when he started,
he had to work to get to where he was at and,
and a,
a lot of these guys do,
some of them,
you know,
again,
they come in and they already got it.
You know,
like Lebron,
he was,
you know,
plan and Groans Ma grown man's game right when he got into the league,
thrown into the fire.
But he was ready for that.
He got better and,
and learn the role and learned who he was as he's gone.
But he was one of those rare thing,
rare people that can just jump into it.
Some people have to get better at it.
And you know,
it's the same thing with music.
Like you get thrown on on that big stage for the first time.
If you're not prepped for it,
you're going to definitely be nervous.
Now you could either embrace that and it'll,
it'll be your first show and you could do a good one or you could do a horrible
one.
But either way you can learn from that.
And uh,
if you don't learn from it,
then the run is short.
If you learn from it,
you know,
you learn how to get better and sustain a longer career.
How did you learn how to get over the anxiety,
like your first show,
having a,
the first show suck like that.
What was the,
what was,
what did you learn?
Like how did you,
how did you take classes?
Did you read a book?
You know,
what we did that helped me was that we rehearsed a lot because for me it was
like more remembering the songs.
It wasn't like the nerve to go out in front of people because we came from the
break dance and be boy culture,
the popping and stuff like that.
So much of that is going against someone battling someone in front of a crowd.
And if you can be in front of a crowd doing that,
cause that's vulnerable.
I mean,
you know,
because in a battle you could either win or you lose.
And if you lose,
you know,
obviously you could lose it in an embarrassing way or you lose in a close
battle.
But either way people are sitting there watching you,
judging you either cheering your boo and you wouldn't,
you know,
any one of those.
So that helped me be able to get on stage and perform in front of people.
It for more from me,
it was more about knowing the songs,
making sure that I know him through the nervousness,
you know?
And so for us,
we did a lot of rehearsals in the early days just so that those first shows that
we did,
that we were locked in and we made an impression.
And you know,
when we did that and we saw the results of how people were reacting to our show,
it gave me more confidence.
So,
you know,
I'd,
I'd rehearse the songs in my head,
you know,
when I wasn't around the other guys,
I'd be kicking the songs and I'd be,
or be on a treadmill working out,
say in the songs,
you know,
getting them in my head and just gave me the confidence that I know this fucking
shit.
I go up there,
I'll rock this fucking thing.
I'm not going to forget it because that's always the problem for me.
It was never getting in front of people.
It was do I know my shit and now I know it in such a way that like,
you know,
it's second nature.
Do I still get those nervous butterflies?
Yeah,
for sure.
Some shows depending who's watching,
who's on the side stage or how big the crowd is and whatnot.
Yeah,
I still get some of that.
But you know,
I,
I do a quick meditation before I go out there,
you know,
just in my head real quick.
And then our band prayer.
And then that's the,
that's the switch right there.
And we go and we're ready.
And it,
but it took me a while to get to that,
you know,
because it takes work.
It's like anything,
if you're athlete,
if you're a boxer,
you're only gonna get better by boxing all the time.
Training all the time,
not overtraining,
but making sure that you're in,
they're putting in the work.
And it's the same thing when you're rocking stages,
you know,
um,
a lot of us sometimes forget to go and put the time in and rehearse and you
could see that when there's a sloppy show or someone's out of breath,
or they're not saying the whole line,
or they said the line wrong,
or they're changing up fragments of the song to make it easier for their
performance and it doesn't necessarily fit.
That's when,
you know,
somebody ain't putting in the work.
But for us,
you know,
we always,
that was a part of the draw for Cypress.
That's how he won a lot of people over was the energy of our live show.
So,
um,
but it took that the rehearsals,
men and I would tell any artists coming up right now,
man,
before you start doing your shows you,
because you may get a hit like that fast these days and you may be called to go
do that show.
Now.
If you don't do that show right and you suck as good as that song is,
you're never going to sell tickets when they fucking say,
hey,
so and so's performing at the,
you know,
this place,
ah fuck that.
I'd rather just listen to the record.
He sucks life,
you know,
so the rehearse man rehearse and then after that,
hey,
take,
you know,
do what you will.
But those they fucking help man.
You know,
for your confidence on performing the song.
That's a wise thing to tell people,
man.
Beat up professional.
Be a pro.
You can be a professional.
Decide you're a professional that's right in that fucking work.
That work does give you confidence and it works.
It works with fighting.
It works with comedy.
I'm sure it works with everything.
Yeah man.
You gotta be proficient,
professional de professional and official at the same time,
produce show,
what is the meditation that you do?
Just the self awareness,
you know what I mean,
like the circular breathing,
you know,
and uh,
concentrating on that and in the moment and then,
you know,
just letting that clear in my head,
you know what I mean?
Just focus,
focusing on the breathing.
I mean that's what they tell you pretty much in any meditation to focus on the
breathing and all these things are gonna come through your head.
But if you keep on focusing on that,
you know,
everything sort of goes away and your,
your reset.
So,
you know,
I'll,
I'll do that when,
when I feel maybe some sort of anxiety before going on.
If I don't feel that I don't necessarily do the meditation on,
we'll just do the prayer and that's sort of like,
you know,
sets it all in.
But yeah,
like some shows,
man,
I'll,
I'll have to like go in a room and just sit there and you know,
do the breathing man.
And it helps people might think about what the fuck is I going to do?
It's going to reset your mind and give you some clarity,
you know,
for me at least that's what it did.
What's the biggest crowd you guys ever performed in front of?
Um,
I think the biggest was Wa with stock 94,
I think it was 93,
94 and that was like 300 and 380,
some odd thousand.
We've done some big ones like
European country.
We,
we've done sounds like,
you know,
like at,
100,000 people,
100 videos.
Oh my God.
I got to see this fucking insane.
That is insane.
I had just cut my hair right there.
I was like,
you know,
whew.
Oh my God.
See the little guy next to mugs.
He was our,
our,
our uh,
our miniature knockout guy.
He knew Jujitsu,
taekwondo showed up.
[inaudible] he trained with,
with my boy Kenji,
and he was,
he was like,
uh,
he was like our unofficial security and that's hilarious.
Cause Unassuming,
right?
Yeah,
he's a little guy.
I mean he even did,
he even did a few MMA fights.
Some years fucking crowd.
I almost lost my shit right here because you know,
seeing 300 and some odd thousand people jumping around to your shit.
God,
you know,
it could give you some equilibrium problems
cause it's the,
it looks like waves crashing into each other when it's that big.
I mean,
that's gotta be one of the biggest concert ever anybody's ever performed in
front of,
in North America for sure.
I mean in all of human history.
Yeah.
It was one of the biggest,
how the fuck you mean?
What do,
how do you get it more than 380,000 people together?
Yeah.
That's probably only happened a few times.
It's,
it's crazy.
I mean,
every band they had on this,
this particular bill was huge at the time.
He knows so it was,
yeah,
it was,
it was pretty crazy trying to just get there.
We like some of,
had to get in through boat.
Some of us had to get in through helicopter.
Why?
Cause there's so many.
Because they had started parking on the roads,
like the old school to Woodstock and they jacked up the highways and stuff like
that.
They parked like they pretty much shut the shit down
and I went in through helicopter and some of the other guys went into the book.
That's when you know you're on top of the world flying into a show in a fucking
helicopter girl.
That's when you realize why you can never get away from the cops when they're
fucking see everything.
But that's a funny thing man.
When you watch those dudes that are trying to escape from the cops on the ground
and then you watched the cops in the helicopter,
the spotlight just stay in the car the entire time.
They'll get that area.
That's,
yeah,
that's,
and that's just a piece of it right there.
And they had a rotating stage.
What are you doing?
You have to take a shit.
Like how long does it take to get from the front row to the back?
I'll take your shit tell you.
We walked around in that shit right there and it was super muddy and crazy and
people were like,
button naked with mud smeared all over there.
Fucking bodies.
It was like people went primal.
I swear to God it,
there you go right there.
They were having mud slide.
Laurie's.
Oh man,
that looks awesome.
People made babies that Dan their tent.
I'm sure they did a for sure they did.
I yeah sure.
There's a lot of people out there right now.
It was,
it was,
it was fucking crazy man.
I got to tell you there was,
there was people out there totally hippied out like straight up butt naked in
the,
you know,
and there was a good portion of them.
I mean not,
not in terms of the whole concert of is a small percentage,
but like you've seen just naked people walking around free out there.
It was crazy as fuck.
We like are we,
is this really happening shit man.
And then the mud was so thick,
man.
It was the type where like if you walked through it with your shoes and your
shoes weren't tight or you weren't wearing boots,
it was sucking the shoe right off of your foot.
It happened to me a number of times hell and that show I jumped into the crowd
cause normally I would jump into the crowd and uh,
you know,
just be floating,
stage dive style.
But I would still be doing the song right.
And uh,
on that particular show they took my shoes and socks.
I got back on stage with no,
she was in socks.
And you know,
about 15 years later,
you know,
I had one guy with one shoe come to show,
inflict and have me sign it.
Oh.
And then the other shoe,
some,
uh,
some chick had it and had me sign it later.
So I caught up with both shoes.
The socks didn't catch up with the socks,
didn't catch up to stocks,
but the shoes yet caught up with them.
What do they have a limited amount of tickets for Woodstock?
I mean,
what the fuck did they do when you get that many people?
I think they probably started with some sort of limit and became Kay and then it
became chaos,
you know,
like did something they couldn't handle.
I mean if you lived there,
stretch it to send it upon your stuff.
I know they were pissed off.
They had a break for like fucking 25 years.
They had a break.
They sold 164,000 tickets,
but the crowd estimated size was 550,000.
Okay.
Well Shit,
I was too short.
It's 200,000 short.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because the rest rush the gate,
they took the fence and you know,
took it down and they just fucking rolled rolled on me.
I would imagine.
Yeah,
it,
you know,
cause when it's an event that everybody wants to get to,
they're going to find a way to it and it's outside.
It's outside with those numbers,
man.
That's just,
you can't stop that.
I'm no it,
you know,
it's,
it's a great part of their history because I mean,
you know,
that one was a good one where no one got hurt,
knows no crazy,
uh,
no crazy shit happening.
Like the next one after that.
I mean they had,
so what happened to the next one?
Uh,
well shit,
they had a bunch of,
uh,
women say that they had gotten raped or molested at um,
at the,
at the one the following year.
Um,
and uh,
it was fires and shit at the end and then there was fires.
There was a whole bunch of people lost their fucking mind and they had some
great bands too.
So you know it,
they don't do that anymore.
Right.
What stocks know that they're doing it at enough.
What are you doing?
You fucking idiots move,
sell your house and do something.
And it's crazy though,
cause there's a fire is holy shit man.
Yeah.
They had bonfires.
Believe when get corn went on it was either limp biscuit or corn and the fires
just fucking started.
People were pissed too cause they were charging so much for water and like they
couldn't,
they couldn't get to the bathrooms.
Like you're asking,
like they didn't have the facilities set up as well.
Yeah.
They didn't have adequate facilities for what,
what the fuck was popping to mean,
you know,
uh,
a spouse,
Christ,
look at the fucking wood it looks like after it's over.
Listen to thousand Andy Gumps for 500,000 people is nothing
you imagined you need like 10,000.
He can imagine being the dude.
It gets in there up to 5,000.
I mean,
look,
it's taking a shit.
They totally took over the fucking the highway.
Right?
They're crazy.
They shut down the fucking highway.
They just parked their cars.
Yeah,
they made the highway.
The park is crazy.
Look at that.
At least it was kind of orderly.
Like maybe they sort of sort of,
they shut down.
I'll tell you this though.
They weren't cold blooded.
Um,
the,
the organizers,
because
these guys had some fucking Moxy,
I'll tell you that.
Hey listen,
you know,
after every band was done with their set,
they expected you to leave right away because the next wave of bands was coming
and they were getting your spot.
So like if you had a dressing room,
once you're set was done,
you were expected to get the fuck out.
So you had a helicopter out of there.
If,
if,
yeah,
it was best if you did because if you didn't take the ride when,
when,
when you were supposed to,
you are getting stuck there.
They couldn't guarantee that they could give you the ride back to your shit
after that,
you know,
because they had all the other bands to think of and they might not have room
for you when they take the other bands.
So it was like,
yeah,
get that fucking Fisher.
Yup.
Oh my God,
look,
it looks like,
like the stage,
right.
That's insane.
That picture is insane.
Yeah,
it was.
That's,
that's the one I'll remember the most.
I mean we've,
we've done some huge gigs,
but like that one by far,
you know,
never have we played for another 500,000 you know us sound like 500,000 people
screen.
Much like that Viking chant.
I mean we had a small nation right there.
Graziel legitimately like when you leave there and then you go do a regular gig
afterwards.
Does it feel weird?
He,
well,
it,
it depends,
but yeah,
adjusting.
It does take some adjusting,
you know,
especially if the next Gig isn't as hype as that you're like,
fuck,
we just came from Woodstock.
But fortunately the smaller gigs that we had after that,
you know,
in terms of playing festivals,
they were like,
you know,
in between 30,000,
seventy thousand two hundred thousand and we felt it.
That gave us such an experience that we can handle any fucking stage.
So it became easier for us to do festivals after that.
And the reaction that we would get at these festivals were smaller versions of
what we did there,
you know?
And uh,
it was,
it was a great experience because we had,
we had been doing like a,
a couple of European festivals before that,
so it sort of prepared us for that.
But we didn't,
we didn't,
I mean,
the fucking numbers we were definitely not prepared for were like,
Whoa,
what the fuck?
That's like,
that transcends reality.
Yeah.
I mean,
listen,
we know that that's not our show.
They're not all there for us.
You know,
cause it's a mixed bag,
right.
Bunch of different artists and you're winning over people.
If anything you're,
you're,
you're there playing for your,
your,
your base of people that might have come to see you,
but you're winning everybody else over if you're doing it right.
And,
uh,
for us it was like a victory because we saw,
you know,
half a million people up there jumping up and down to all our shit and they knew
the words and they were singing with us in it,
you know,
it was like a,
a big notch under the belt and a boost for our confidence,
knowing that we can get in front of anybody,
play with anyone and get that reaction.
I mean,
because after that,
you know,
we were getting booked on metal,
um,
driven festivals and stuff where we're the only hip hop on it,
but it's all straight up metal.
I mean we were playing shows,
um,
co headlining under Metallica,
right?
Metallica,
Cypress Hill,
um,
uh,
biohazard,
Deftones fear factory in,
in all of that stuff.
You know what I mean?
And we'd be in that mix playing those festivals with those guys and with hip hop
music and you know,
the boost did,
it gave us in the confidence,
it was like,
fuck that we can play with any of these motherfuckers.
It doesn't matter who it is.
And,
and we went to those metal metal festivals with our hip hop in,
got metal reaction,
mosh pits,
stage dives,
everything what,
you know,
and,
and it felt good to be able to hang up there with Metallica.
I mean,
yeah,
what they do to a crowd is crazy.
But we realized that if we were playing on the same venue going before them,
we can in a festival form,
we can fucking hang with anyone.
And,
and uh,
that's,
that pretty much put us over the top with doing festivals.
Like,
yeah,
we're,
we're going to fucking rule this shit.
People are going to have to,
people are going to have to up their game when we're on that festival with them.
That's the way we took it.
And I would imagine you couldn't sleep for days after that chair.
The adrenaline was crazy.
I got to tell you,
the adrenaline was crazy and then you're in the helicopter leaving.
Will you like what the fuck just happened?
Yeah,
we were,
we were tripping out man.
I mean,
we were like totally in awe of,
of the response that we got and the,
the,
you know,
the enormity of the fucking crowd man.
I mean,
it was fucking huge.
Is to be a part of something.
That's that,
I mean,
that's like something that no one there is ever going to forget.
We took it for granted.
I've got to tell you when we fucking,
they'll,
well,
they want you to do well.
Okay,
we'll do Woodstock,
whatever.
And,
and,
and uh,
when we got there,
that's when we saw just how fucking crazy it was.
I think this yet seen you'll,
they steal your shoes.
They're going to start coming to watch.
I have to hold my shirt forward so they don't get choked out.
And there goes,
there goes the first shoes.
Not to take that first one.
What were you thinking when they were taking shit like damn.
I was like,
Oh fuck.
There goes one shoe,
there goes all white sock.
She,
yeah,
that goes the other so ridiculous and there is no fucking security that can stop
500,000 people save all that shit.
No,
you're at the mercy of the fans so,
but he's going to grab from my sock pretty soon.
That is so wild and is stealing socks.
Look at it.
It's still your pants.
Hey listen.
You know they,
they,
they tried in big grab your Dick now that you know,
they tried to grab the weed in my pocket cause that sometimes you know,
when your adrenaline is kicking you're not really thinking,
you know what's in my pocket and shit like that.
But yeah.
You know,
throughout the,
I had chicks trying to grab my shit for sure.
Of course.
The,
sure that was a little crazy for me,
you know?
But it is what it is.
If you're going to stand close.
Yeah.
You know,
Shit like this happens,
right?
I mean if you're going to stage dive,
you got to assume some weird shit is going to happen.
Yeah.
I mean for me,
you know,
people were mostly respectful,
but they would go through my pockets to see if I had weed in one.
One didn't have any or your pockets.
Yeah,
I did.
I had some,
I had like an ounce of weed and one at one show and I jumped in and I totally
forgot I had it in my pocket.
Boom.
If I can took my goddamn week.
Hope you enjoyed that.
I bet they did.
Actually.
They did their role in that joint.
This is be real and weed man.
I know they do in California.
This is the real shit.
Yeah.
California.
We to this day still holds up.
I mean,
you got some good Colorado.
We,
there's some good weed all over the country,
but oh,
Swede is,
it's like,
okay.
It's okay.
Other places Rato and California and then the rest is kind of,
Seattle's got real good weed.
Seattle actually blow your fucking mind.
They'll blow your mind.
Yeah.
I gotta say Oregon.
They'll blow your mind.
People have stepped up,
they're still behind California.
And you know,
in terms of how much good weed there is here,
like,
I mean,
there's so much,
you know,
from north to south and in central cow,
there's so many different strains that are fucking good,
right?
You go to other places and they have a few strains that are good,
but that's because they're still,
you know,
they're still trying to catch up in terms of knowledge and cultivation and stuff
like that in,
in,
in how to make this trains that they have,
you know,
maximize the flavor in,
in,
in the high and all that stuff.
Some of caught up and some are still lagging a little bit behind.
But I gotta tell you,
man,
when this last trip I just had to Vancouver,
I was just there,
um,
for four 20.
And uh,
they had some shit that California boys would be like,
Yo,
this is fire right here.
You know,
they had a animal cookies that were really good wedding cake,
which is a strain.
It's popular here in Cali,
you know,
via the jungle boys and,
and a burner and stuff like that.
When they were,
when they were working together on exotics and uh,
and they also had this,
this joint called black diamond and try octane and all of them men,
I got to say all of them burn suite.
They tasted good that that white ash did.
People are looking for.
Now,
you know,
people think,
when they see white ash,
it's the purist,
um,
news flash.
Even if it has a little bit of black ash,
it's still,
you know,
there's still,
people clean,
flush their roots,
you know what I mean?
It's just,
it,
some of the nutrients,
if you're using salts as your nutrients,
you know,
which most people are these days,
your ash comes out.
Like if you're using nutrients that are already pre made like an advanced
nutrients in the others,
sometimes you know,
you might have a little bit of black ash because some of the components into
those nutrients doesn't mean it's not clean.
It just looks prettier when it's white.
But anyway,
these guys,
their shit,
all white ash and the taste was fucking beautiful in the high was definitely
there.
And I say,
guys in Vancouver,
man,
they,
they have stepped up.
Oh,
well they've been running,
we'd through Vancouver for a long time.
Do you ever say that?
What,
what is Adam's gorgeous documentary?
He had the culture high and then before that there was another one,
the documentary that was all about uncovering how much of Vancouver's entire
economy is based on marijuana.
And if he pulled it out,
like when they talk about,
uh,
the union,
that's it.
The business mind getting high.
Um,
when,
if you pulled weed out of Vancouver,
you took it out of their economy,
their economy would essentially collapse.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's responsible for so many people being wealthy up there.
And it's,
so it was,
now it's 100% legal throughout the entire country.
Yeah.
But back then in 2007,
I was in that documentary.
That was 12 years ago.
It was just tolerated.
It was weirdly tolerated where it wasn't legal,
but they didn't ever arrest anybody for it.
But there was a lot of gangsters,
a lot of hell's angels were involved.
A lot of dudes were selling weed and they had flashy diamond colored watt
covered watches and shit.
There was a lot of that shit.
Yeah.
You know,
it's still sort of,
um,
I mean,
you know,
listen,
the black market's always going to be,
you know,
anywhere.
Especially right now that the taxes are so high to buy cannabis and to grow it
and all that stuff,
everything did involves it.
It's pretty expensive right now.
So they're encouraging organized crime,
right.
In a certain way.
Yeah.
Which my point was,
you know,
when the corporations come in,
that shit comes down and then the black market has a bigger problem at that
point because then prices of cannabis will come down.
Um,
but you know,
it's always going to exist in,
in,
you know,
we sort of went through the same thing when,
when to 15 came about here in California where it was,
you know,
cops didn't know what the fuck to do when they caught you with it.
They didn't want to do anything,
you know,
because they knew as well as we were,
this shit is eventually going to be legal.
They don't want to be wasting their time and putting people in jail for,
for cannabis because you know,
there's other people that need to be in jail for real,
for real crimes.
Um,
but um,
yeah,
I think what's happening in Vancouver now is that now that it's legal,
people are still making money and they're still,
you know,
they're still on top of the game,
but it's,
it's,
it's harder to make the money right now.
Well at least,
well maybe not for Canada because it's federally legal,
but you still got to jump through a number of hoops,
you know,
in terms of regulation and fines and fees and shit like that to operate,
and they're a little bit different than ours.
Obviously we're not,
ours isn't like federal yet.
But,
uh,
I mean,
you know,
from what they were saying is that like,
in a few years all these companies will be making a whole lot of money.
Right now they're making money,
but it's basically about survival.
Getting past a certain time when all the,
all the legislation,
all the rules and all the regulations are finally set in place and they're not
going to change from year to year.
Like they,
like they have been.
So,
you know,
well,
Denver had a real weird for a while where they weren't allowed to use banks.
Yeah.
You know,
like us right now here in Cali,
we can't use banks.
Yeah.
What did they do with it?
So they see,
can they use credit cards here?
They used to be able to,
yeah,
you can use credit cards.
Um,
but realistically it's,
it's if you're making money from,
from cannabis in terms of if you're a cultivator or you're a or whatever,
if you're a business entity in the cannabis world,
they won't take your money if they know it's coming from the cannabis cannabis
culture.
Right.
But,
you know,
in the last,
in the last two months,
they've,
you know,
Forbes just put out a story about that the federal government is going to stout
start allowing banks to,
uh,
to allow banking in the cannabis and the cannabis stock going anywhere.
They'd be crazy to not,
you're just leaving money on the table.
You're leaving a whole lot of money on the table.
California considers plan to encourage marijuana banking.
Yes.
And that,
and that just came out yesterday.
You know,
the Forbes story came out like maybe last week or something,
but this is,
you know,
one of the residuals of it is it,
in places like California that we had problems with banking that is no longer
going to exist.
So now if you needed to expand your business or something,
you get a business loan now or you can actually put your money in the fucking
bank,
you know,
whereas before you had to fucking buy some sort of vault or some shit and keep
it there.
And uh,
you know,
obviously that ain't safe because you got pirates out there still to this day
trying to figure out,
okay where do they keep their money?
Cause it's that bank.
But when I was in Colorado,
when it first became legal and they were having a real hard,
they couldn't use credit cards ever.
It was all cash and they just had spec ops guys everywhere.
Bulletproof vests just covered with guns just ready to rock at any moment's
notice.
And they were worried that they were going to get,
you know,
yeah.
Someone was going to try to take over the store and take all the money.
Yeah.
I mean there's still issues that they got to worry about moving into the future
in terms of transport protection.
Right.
You know,
because throughout,
throughout the history of doing any sort of business terms of products going
from one side of the nation to the other,
you know,
trucks get hijacked a lot for electronics,
for any sort of goods.
So,
you know,
when you're transporting cannabis from state to state,
they're going to have to have that,
you know,
figured out too because there's,
people that are going to be trying to,
those trucks in hitting that into the black market.
You know,
what else is weird?
There's people that they post up on people's private land and start these,
grows these grow centers,
put up a garden and people's land.
Like I,
I've a friend works on a ranch and a in like central California and they were
uh,
doing this Ron,
they were checking gates and checking fences for where the cattle are and they
found like a fucking acre of wheat.
They're like,
what the fuck is this?
And there was some dudes there,
they had camp grounds set up and shit and yeah,
it was like they were just,
they were cartel dudes.
They just like set up a spot,
find a spot set up.
They don't know who fucking owns it and if they,
you know,
dropped off there,
apparently they,
I think if I remember the story,
they got the guys and the guys basically explained how it worked,
that they get dropped off and they get,
you know,
the,
the leave them with seeds and this and that and then new guys come in every
couple of weeks or a couple months and they live there and just watch the weed
until it grows to the point where they can cultivate it and then they move on
after it's done.
But they just all over the place.
People find them in like state parks and forests and shit,
like hiking.
That's why it happens mostly up north and in central countdown here.
We don't really,
I mean the way they patrol the state parks is slightly different down here in
the south.
They'll,
they'll catch that shit.
That's why they did it at the ranch because it was to hone ranch,
which is like two to hold ready thousand acres.
It's a huge place that I believe natives own that,
that ranch.
Right?
Yeah.
You can find to this day these stones where they ground up acorns,
where they have like a little,
like a pivot,
like a hole where the ground it up.
I took pictures of it and shit.
It's pretty cool cause you gotta think like that's probably a thousand years
old.
Yeah.
Someone who's probably grind in acorns and there a thousand years and years ago.
I've never been up north to Humboldt.
I'd never been up to that area.
Oh that it's,
it's uh,
it's unique.
There's a lot of Nice flavors up there.
Um,
if you're in the glass,
the,
a lot of good glass blowers out there.
But that's a long standing weed culture.
Oh yeah.
I mean that shit is generational right there.
I was like from the 70s.
Yeah,
I heard about Humboldt in,
I'll tell you man,
you know,
it is quiet as they've been in this cannabis culture,
you would think that that,
that'd be one place that's like celebrated and whatnot.
But I mean they still are coming up with,
you know,
incredible flavors down there,
in terms of,
uh,
you know,
breeding certain,
certain,
um,
certain strains in creating new strains in doing it outside,
you know,
like with the,
as they call sun grown or,
or a greenhouse,
you know,
which is not something we do here in the south.
In the south.
We'd,
we'd do hydro.
It's,
you know,
indoor,
cause we don't have the same type of
moisture and shit.
Well we don't the space neither,
you know,
the forest digit and the moisture and uh,
we have,
we have insects that would eat those outdoor crops if they're not in a
greenhouse.
You know what I mean?
Like fruit worms and shit like that up there.
And you know,
up north after dark,
you know it gets cold.
So some of those,
those insects can't live in that,
that environment.
But in the south it doesn't get as cold as it does up there so they can live
here.
So you know,
if you're going to do a greenhouse,
here you go.
It's got to be a greenhouse.
It can't just be outdoor exposed because they will get,
they will get fucked with for sure.
Those photos that I've seen of that area is everything so fucking green.
That's crazy.
It's like Seattle almost.
Yeah,
it's awesome,
man.
We were just there not too long ago.
Plan to show up and you
look at that guy,
the middle of this forest of we on a hillside.
No,
unless you know that even a flat ground and he's just,
he got it going.
Yeah.
That looks like he's just in the woods.
He just started growing it in the woods.
That's crazy.
Wow.
I bet it has a different feel to it.
Right?
It's always out there with nature.
I mean,
I think it's strong hippie too.
Hippy dippy.
But I would think that something that lives in nature with all those other trees
and shits communicating with those trees.
Oh yeah.
I would think so.
You'll probably get more of like a natural feel for the weed.
Yeah,
they're probably deer.
Damn.
Look at the weed plant like they fucking bushes.
Jesus Christ.
40 black tail right there.
Columbia black tail.
It's a big deer and there's a big fear part of the probably eat the weed.
Probably probably healthy as fuck.
I mean if he's eating the seeds and shit easy.
Yeah,
probably fertilizing some of that shit out there.
For the longest time we used to have to get,
you know,
I'm,
I'm one of the owners of on it and when we made hemp protein we just have to buy
or shift from Canada.
It was so stupid.
I was like,
this is so ridiculous.
You have to buy a hamp from another country.
Bring into this country stupid.
Well that's going to change for sure.
Yes.
That's got to change.
I mean for,
for everything,
for clothing,
even building houses,
you ever see that hempcrete that that shit they make.
It's like a camp concrete.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
Lighter.
It's better.
It's got better insulation values.
It's harder to burn.
This is the type of shit that jacker rare was trying to tell people in emperor
wearing the emperor wears no clothes.
No daily was all this stuff that we use today.
Hemp can be,
you know,
the,
the alternative at a cheaper cost,
including plastic,
biodegradable plastic.
All these people that are worried about plastic bottles and everything,
how bad they are for the environment.
Hamp bottles.
You could make plastic at a hemp and it would be biodegradable.
Yeah.
It sounds like horse shit.
There's so many things that you could do with weed that it sounds like you're
making things.
It sounds like you're making it up,
but it's actual,
it's actual fact.
Yeah.
And Dude,
over the last like couple of months,
I've been fucking around pretty heavily with CBD.
Like every day I've been taking this,
this is a,
it's a one in one.
It's 10 of CBD,
10 milligrams of Thc.
I take this,
that's,
that's the perfect one.
One in the afternoon.
Ooh.
All Day long.
All full of don't give a fuck juice.
Just
we all need that.
Awesome.
That's an interesting time.
Yeah.
You know,
for someone who was,
you know,
used to have to hide it before.
Yeah.
In,
you know,
that's the beauty of it now is it,
you don't have to hide it.
And people that used to,
you know,
you got people now that you've never thought were smokers and you know,
now they're coming out and just being totally free with it.
And that's great man.
You know,
cause that hap laptop,
what the fuck is that must be a cover but yeah,
that's pretty cool.
How could it be a cover of,
it's like the USB ports and everything like that.
They have those like skin covers.
It could just be a lookalike,
but it looks like they should make it
a four time.
It is.
I got to agree.
Well listen brother,
you're a bad motherfucker.
I really appreciate you.
Thank you brother forever,
for a long time.
So it's cool to get in here and,
uh,
when a hot boxes to get in that smoke box and people have been asking for you
for a long time.
I got to,
and,
and I say this,
you know,
in some of the,
some of the smoke boxes,
you know,
like,
Eh,
cause it's the real his shit.
Like we just had Mike Tyson in there,
you know.
And um,
how weird is it to smoke weed with?
My title was,
I,
I've smoked with them before and,
and I,
I've smoked it with him on a couple set separate occasions aside from there.
But one of the places that I smoked with him was at that fucking Leo Machida
Rashad Evans fight when we all left,
you know,
after the fight,
we were sort of a getting to our cars and he ran into me and my partner Kenji
and we were smoking if that one right there and you know,
they'd be real
well,
is that all right?
Fuck yeah.
Champion.
Here you go.
And,
and um,
you know,
we always knew he smoked out.
What was crazy about this interview real quick that did,
I'll say it like,
cause you asked me this in this interview,
like what did you do for the anxieties before?
Like,
you know,
let's say you were going to go on stager,
do the shit.
Right.
So I asked him that similar question.
I said,
you know,
as artists,
as athletes will before we're going to go do our thing in front of a mass amount
of people,
you get this nervous energy,
what did you do to,
you know,
deal with that?
And he said,
you think it hitting the type before faith?
Yeah.
You know,
and he was saying how he would,
the guys that were working with him would,
uh,
instill these certain words,
like calmness,
you know,
that would be a reoccurring word that they would do in the hypnosis,
in hypnotizing them before a fight.
So that he would always be calm in the fight and never fight desperate and
always be in control of the situation no matter what happened.
And that's how he would,
you know,
get that nervous energy down and,
and,
uh,
be able to fight with such focus.
But the other interesting thing he said was that he never fought.
I mean,
he was smoking the whole time,
you know,
he's a big weed head since he was like 10 years old apparently.
But he said that he was smoking,
you know,
but not necessarily when he was training,
they would give him pharmaceuticals when he was training,
you know,
shit that he wouldn't feel nothing,
but he didn't have focus.
What kind of pharmaceuticals?
He said,
uh,
some of it was phentenol,
some Percocet,
some fentanyl wasn't even around back.
Well,
it's a form of it,
you know,
like whatever.
Yeah,
it was an opiate that was whatever the fence and all of that time,
whenever,
I can't remember what he called it,
but there was two or three prescription drugs that they would give him it and he
said he,
he wouldn't feel nothing.
He felt good.
Like there's no pain,
no nothing.
But the focus that he had was,
was not,
not there.
Right.
He said that he smoked weed in one fight.
Mikey smoked weed before one particular fight and,
and he used the wizard Nader to get through the urine test.
Somehow he fucking,
he says it in the interview and you know,
he said that the fight that he had where he was smoked out was with Andrew
Gelada.
He said he'd never had so much focus in a fight that it made him realize he
should have been smoking weed through every God damn fight because he focused on
everything he was supposed to.
He said he broke his cheek,
he broke his,
uh,
his cheek here.
Orbital ba broke his orbital.
He broke a rib and part of his back with a body shots,
Christ.
And he said,
you know,
that was the fight that was the one and only fight that he,
smoked out beforehand.
And Andrew Gelada got,
he got a flat line.
He,
Andrew go out of left the ring.
He was like,
fuck this.
And Andrew Gelada had been through wars.
I mean Riddick both fights were crating Riddick both fights.
I mean cause Riddick Bowe was really good,
you know,
but he didn't hit like Mike.
No,
no,
no.
I don't think no one hit like Mike,
if you look at like some of his early training.
Oh crazy legs.
He was so crazy back then.
If you look at some of my early training in his footwork,
it's almost like,
you know,
almost like martial arts based,
the way that he attacked and then he shifts on his attack and his focused tomato
custom motto was a master master.
Yeah.
It wasn't until he switched up and got rid of Kevin Rooney and you know where
the destruction starts,
how I think it was also his,
you know,
his life was just too crazy.
It was just too crazy.
No one can manage that from the time of these 20 to,
you know,
by the time he retired,
I mean it was probably just a whirlwind of chaos.
And it's crazy because he realizes that like looking back at it and he says that
he doesn't train anymore because it awakens a beast.
And he said that it made me nervous cause it said it cause he said that to you
too,
right?
Yeah.
Cause that,
cause I was watching you know,
your interview with them and uh,
one of our guys that was in the backseat asked him,
Hey,
do you ever train?
Do you ever like,
you know,
he's like,
Nah,
I don't do that.
No.
Yeah,
he was.
Every night I get on the treadmill and I do it from running on the treadmill,
but that fit,
I would imagine that if he got back and train and he get in shape real quick,
but you know,
it would awaken a beast.
Yeah.
They're all like,
you can't quit.
You can't quit.
He's like,
fuck you.
Fuck you.
And rounded.
Just got up and left,
pushed that guy away.
And he's like,
you're not filling these punches.
He knew something was wrong.
Well he knew his buzz I bought was broke too.
Look,
they're trying to put the mouthpiece.
He put it in it's Luva.
Yes.
Lou Duvel do voters.
Who is that guy looked like Lou dealer for a second.
Yeah,
he's,
I mean,
you could tell his fucking face as Busey,
right?
They're fairly normal,
but I'm sure it felt like shit,
you know,
like it doesn't swell up real bad until later he listened.
You know,
if Andrew Gelada,
you know who's been in wars,
you know with Riddick Bowe and other fighters,
like he was a no slouch.
If he's telling you I've had enough of this shit,
wow,
we'll let him go.
Because he knows once they found out that his back was broken in,
his face was broken.
They're probably like,
oh,
okay.
Sorry.
Yeah.
I mean they think about that.
Here's a corner guy was like trying to put his mouthpiece backend so stupid once
it got,
doesn't want to fight.
You can't make them fight more.
It's like he's already flipped that switch inside of his head.
You know what I told Mike that he didn't realize it.
If this is the last thing,
cause I know we both got to go,
but I said,
do you know that all the dudes you fought to get to that title,
including,
you know the dudes that you know that,
that you took titles from,
they all stopped fighting after you beat him.
None of them wanted to come back and get nothing.
They didn't want no part of that heavyweight title after that.
He retired so many boxers.
Oh yeah.
He doesn't even realize that Tony tubs go down the line.
All of them.
He didn't retire.
Larry Holmes,
wait until he went to jail and he's like,
I'm going to come back.
Yup.
Yeah.
That's the only guy.
Bone crusher Smith.
Yup.
Tyrrell bigs.
Definitely retired to and they were rivals at one point in time.
Yeah.
He Fuck Tyrrell did pretty good.
Leon Spinks.
Yeah.
Michael.
He said,
you know what,
I had this title too long.
It's a wrap.
Yeah,
check please.
And he told me just like,
I think you know what?
I didn't even realize that.
Yeah,
man know what he did.
He retired.
A lot of people say we all saw it.
It was a force of nature.
And I told him the other thing I told him real quick too was,
you know,
like that explanation that he had on his documentary where he as he's coming to
the ring,
he knew he had to fight one.
He could see it in their eyes and then once he steps into the ring,
he's a god,
they're done right.
And I told him,
you know,
I was at that Bruce Seldon fight and um,
I saw exactly what you explained in Bruce Selten Cause Bruce Selden was knocking
fools out left and right.
He was like a really good heavyweight.
The minute he got in there with Mikey Fan boyed out tasted that glove.
Didn't want no more.
Yeah,
it was a experience.
It wasn't just that you were fighting a guy who knew how to fight,
but you were fighting Mike Tyson.
It was this idol.
He was this thing,
this cultural phenomenon he was thought to be at that time everybody was
thinking he's the greatest heavyweight of all time.
Does it destroyer?
No one had an answer for him.
You know,
sell didn't sell,
then he pretty much,
you know,
he was a fan.
That was his idol and he,
he got totally got rocked.
He was so huge at the time that when buster Douglas beat him,
even though I knew he beat him,
I watched the fight afterwards.
I couldn't believe it.
I'm like,
this is,
he's going to get up and it's Bruce elder.
I look out Jack Bruce Selden was,
he's a big boy and they're fucking tank.
Yeah.
And he was,
he was knocking people out and be look 29 nuggets and he was fighting good guys.
Oh yeah.
Cause the WBA heavyweight champion.
And I followed his career too.
You know what I mean?
And yeah,
he totally fan boyed out on Mike,
man.
I'm like,
well look at the stare down.
We've seen him in the stare down and you look at it that
it's like,
oh no,
you made a tremendous mistake getting to this mistake.
Look how much bigger sell didn't is do it.
He's a big boy,
bro.
It wasn't taken none of that shit.
Tyson's footwork and his ability to close the distance and Bob and weave and I
mean it was like there was nobody before him like that.
No Man,
they'll never be another guy like that.
It's a heavyweight.
He was just so fast too because realistically the guys who trained him,
yeah,
they had a certain technique and nobody uses it.
Well,
it was not just dad,
it was Wa what Mike talked about in the podcast about being hypnotized.
Yeah.
I mean from the time he was a little boy and you know,
the fact that he had nothing before that everything was,
his life was shit.
It was all pain and suffering and poverty.
And then all of a sudden some guy comes along and rescues him and takes some
teaches amount of box and then all of a sudden he gets recognition and positive
feedback and he felt like he was something special.
Boom,
he fucking hit that canvas Holler.
He didn't want it.
We kind of forget sometimes what it was like watching those fights to go back
and watch them now.
I mean there's,
there's amazing fighters right now.
Like the,
like Terrence Crawford had just won a Saturday night.
Amazing,
amazing boxers.
But what Mike was,
was something,
he was something completely different.
It was something that transcended sports.
Everybody wanted to see him fight.
Do you know if you believed in conspiracy theories?
Right?
He didn't even hit him right there.
He just fell on purpose.
Right?
If you believe in conspiracy theories,
right?
You think about it like this,
Mike was knocking guys out in the first round and people were paying a whole lot
of money for,
for tickets and paper view.
You know,
when you look at it,
it looks like they were trying to slow his role and put in a guy like Evander
Holyfield who was a brawler.
He could box but he could brawl and take the fight 11 rounds and you know,
make it a fucking great paper view where Mike would totally ruined the paper.
Have you had knock your ass out in,
in a,
and when you look at it the way boxing was for such a long time,
I wouldn't put it past it.
Did you know a lot of the shit that happened to him?
It was manipulated so that it would slow his role.
What,
what,
what kind of Shit?
Like what do you mean?
Well,
you know,
the people that he had around him,
I mean,
you know,
certainly of the king around a meet,
he took all his,
his,
his people that he trusted away from them,
put different trainers in his corner,
different people that were influenced in him and did it just took him backwards.
Man in,
in all the people that actually helped got him there were fucking gone.
And those were the guys that was actually given him guidance as to,
you know,
how to conduct yourself,
be a man and all that stuff.
And he got around the vultures men and they in to me,
I think don king being don king,
he stood more money.
He stood a chance to make more money with someone taking out the fight,
you know,
11 to 12 rounds as opposed to one while he just,
he gave Mike the worst deals ever to yeah.
And the whole thing was terrible.
He stole money from him to this day.
Mike hates him.
Yeah.
It's all terrible.
Anyway,
I'm make you my man.
Thank you.
I'll see you in a couple of days.
Yeah,
for sure.
Right.
I'm looking forward to it.
Hi,
everybody.
Okay.
Hm?